thanks to joe biden ultra maga is
trending joe biden recently said that
maga is the most extreme political
organization in american history it's
objectively false
because like i don't know the weather
underground existed but sure whatever
the trump supporters waving little
american flags that's what i'm worried
about
i'm sure the left will come out and be
like but the insurrection okay dude sure
whatever i'm not i'm not even bothering
with that no ultra maga he calls it the
ultra maga agenda well
joe biden back in i think it was 1982
you voted to uh not i believe it was
voting against roe v wade so i wonder
what that means about you because if
anything's changed in this country it's
not really been the right except the
rights actually moved leftward
conservatives are now like okay with gay
marriage to a certain degree whereas
they weren't 14 years ago i mean 10
years ago they weren't so if anything's
happened in this country everything's
moved a little bit to the left so joe
biden is absolutely wrong but we'll talk
about this we've got a bunch of other
stuff too will chamberlain
friend of the show produced a thread on
who he thinks may have leaked the scotus
ruling from the supreme court
and derek swalwell
essentially is threatening you know oh
you're gonna get sued or whatever
they're really getting triggered about
this because i think will may have
actually discovered something and well i
don't want to say too much because
they're very litigious people but will
makes the case that it's possible this
person could be somebody who leaked some
information we'll read through what he
said and uh we'll be we'll be careful
about it we've got a bunch of other
stories elon musk we're originally going
to lead with this one there's a there's
an or a 26 leftist organizations calling
for an advertiser boycott of twitter if
elon musk wants to change things so
we've got this article talking about the
legion of doom elon musk slammed this or
this this letter saying who is funding
these people surprise surprise one of
the people is george soros joining us to
talk about all this we've got a couple
different people why don't you guys
introduce yourself so you can start alum
hello i'm alan bakari i'm the senior
tech correspondent for breitbart news
uh
my job is to expose silicon valley and
everything they're doing to manipulate
your elections take your speech away and
harvest your data
i'm john schweppe i'm the policy
director at american principles project
we're a conservative group in d.c and we
also focus on uh big tech issues so alum
and i have had a lot of fun working
together over the last few years uh ian
cross and wild freak and hippie also i
co-founded mines so i'm really down to
get to get to brass tacks about the tech
uh implications what we're seeing here
great to have you guys and i know
basically nothing about tex i'm very
excited to learn about some of that
tonight
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support our journalists and the work we
do as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 pm we'll have
another one of those up on another one
of those up tonight at 11 p.m members
only and you're also keeping our
journalists gainfully employed as we
hire more and expand our news operation
and you're going to allow us to keep
doing our fancy little culture jamming
marketing stuff we have planned a bunch
of cool stuff is in the works we're just
trying to you know i don't know rustle
up some feathers and trigger some
some uh blue check authoritarian
elitists i think we're gonna do a good
job of it it should be really exciting
when i talk to people behind the scenes
about what we have planned they'll just
go whoa are you crazy and i'm like yes
we're some crazy stuff someone suggested
that we hire like a thousand people to
dress up like syringes and go dance
around in dc or something like maybe
that's kind of the crazy kind of stuff
i'm interested in doing and then these
blue checkies will be like who is doing
this and people are running around
dressed up like syringes or whatever so
again go to cast.com become a member but
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel and share the show with your
friends it's time we discuss ultra maga
oh cool joe biden is warning about the
ultra maga agenda that that really does
sound like a trump anime or or manga you
know the ultra maga and they're like
fighting they always end up making uh
the right sound super cool
first it was deplorable
now it's uh now it's ultra maga
ultra
what does it mean i don't know
does it mean it's awesome
look look joe biden was talking about
the roe v wade thing
he's insane he's an insane person okay i
i just have to say that and you know i
always i'm always a little reluctant to
say that because there's going to be
some you know
red pill curious left-leaning person
who's like i guess i'll check out tim
cast irl then then they hear something
like that and they get scared and they
they run away and they're like no he's
far right let me just let me just
explain okay give me a second let me try
and break it down for you
maga is the most extreme political
organization in american history that's
a quote from joe biden the weather
underground was a thing they blew stuff
up and killed people okay biden warned
that after roe v wade was struck down
conservatives might try to ban lgbtq
kids from classrooms
where did that come from
it's like made it up just literally made
that up that's not a thing that's not
happening anywhere but you see this is
what happened
recently joe biden was asked about title
42 and his response was well you gotta
get the scientists have got to review it
you know and then we'll appeal to the
courts and it's like wait what br
joe are you talking about are you
talking about covet or something you're
talking about immigration we're talking
he confused the mass uh mandate repeal
with immigration the man is not well
he is not able to articulate his
thoughts this maga crowd is really the
most extreme political organization
that's existed in american history all
right i'd just like to make one point
joe biden in response to news that the
supreme court voted to overturn roe v
wade said that
that maga is the most extreme political
organization in american history
and it's it is it is based upon
overturning roe v wade all right here
you go joe
biden changed position on roe v wade in
1982 when biden was a senator from
delaware he voted to end roe v wade
under former president ronald reagan the
administration was focused on ending
abortion rights at the federal level an
amendment was proposed to the senate
judiciary committee to allow individual
states to overturn roe v wade he said
i'm probably a victim or a product you
know everyone afraid of my background
citing his catholic upbringing
if anything's more extreme today it's
joe biden
that's a hypocrite
no look the psychological thing
projection right we talk about this all
the time
that's what's happening here obviously
you know you mentioned this tim but
maga you know in a lot of ways is left
of where the republican party is 20
years ago i mean 10 years 10 years ago
um you know you look at like trade and
things like that that was those were
issues where the democrats were um but
but but joe biden and the democratic
party we're talking about abortion till
the moment of birth we're talking about
sex changes for kids we're talking about
censoring free speech so i think when he
says that ultra maga which is really
cool by the way uh is the most dangerous
political movement i i think the truth
is that the democrats are are really
threatening that now the reason biden is
able to get away with this and the
reason why a substantial number of
people in the country will believe him
is because of the media
the media memory holds every single
example of left-wing extremism and
amplifies anything they can pin on
republicans so we'll always remember the
trespasses at the capitol but we won't
remember the people who bombed the
capital in the 1980s uh the leftists
linked to the weather on the ground as
uh as you said tim um actually there
might have been another different
left-wing extremist groups group even
i'm forgetting the deal so many even i'm
forgetting the details because the media
just doesn't
talk about these things ceaselessly
here's the here's here's the issue you
know they come out and they're like but
there's so many far-right extremists and
i'm like there are many far-right
extremists sure but do they have any
institutional power are the people who
stormed into the capital on january 6
working at cnn or the new york times are
any of those people are are they being
supported and defended by cnn in the new
york times oh well when black lives
matter and antifa rioted across this
country in 2020 causing billions of
dollars in damage and i think it
resulted in between 26 and 32 dead
they were actively defended by the
sitting vice president and president
and the media actively defended them my
favorite is fiery but mostly peaceful
so if i take issue with that you know
and then you're like but what about the
insurrectionists and i'm like oh the
people who are violent should go to
prison but those people don't have any
support from the major cultural
institutions they don't work there you
actually have active antifa people at
the new york times
actively
okay you don't you don't have that with
the mag people but they're like but
they're police officers i'm like dude
and what like bumble haven in in in bufu
yeah okay i'm really worried about the
po dunk cop who drove a couple hundred
miles and rioted arrest the guy put him
in jail fine i get it but that is not an
institution that is going to harm my
life and and look at the difference here
between the two parties right the
republicans do everything they can to
disavow the insurrectionists disavow the
far right you know the alt-right people
the democrats create gofundmes for
bailout funds for the pro the the mostly
peaceful protesters
i pulled up this uh the bombing you were
talking about in the capital 1980s a
far-left group called m19
uh bomb the senate huh it was women i
think it was a group of women but it was
like a male oh it wasn't all women it
was like looks like four women and two
guys they call it like a yeah i've never
heard it i don't think i've ever heard
m19 until tonight so thank you yeah
i think a lot of people haven't heard
about it because uh whoever controls the
history books whoever controls the news
doesn't want us remembering it uh you
know we have an alternative news media
now which is great we probably need
alternative history as well yeah their
communist communist organization well
and has everybody forgotten about asada
shakur and her shootout on the jersey
turnpike that was in i want to say the
70s i'm not sure exactly but that's just
another thing that they never ever talk
about incredibly dangerous people
literally died it's just not a big deal
this is crazy look i pulled up m19
from 1982 to 1985 m19 ceo committed a
series of bombings including bombings
the national war college the washington
navy yard computing center the israeli
aircraft industries
new york city's south african consulate
wow the washington navy yard officers
club
they've got a whole bunch here man but
there's no way those guys are the most
extremist movement in american history
that's well well from my god no no hold
on hold on hold on let's be honest and
be real
they didn't vote for trump okay so
everything else it's like it's it's bad
but it's not quite there
it's really like it becomes obvious as
you learn how governments will use
organizations as like fall guys when
it's time ellen it's it's explosive but
mostly peaceful yes
it's bad but not ultra bad yeah exactly
we even have recent examples i mean
that's from the 80s but do you guys
remember the family research council
shooting that happened like six years
ago seven years ago no one talks about
this but this they were targeted for
being an anti-gay hate group and someone
went in there with chick-fil-a
sandwiches was planning to put
chick-fil-a sandwiches on the dead
corpses of all the people that worked
there this happened it wasn't wasn't
that like the splc yeah it was the splc
named them and then so they went after
them no i mean you also had the the
bernie guy who went and shot up the
baseball game
i don't think mag is an organization it
means make america great again it was a
it was a phrase that donald trump used
you could say that people are rallying
around and attempting to create some
sort of organized movement based on
donald trump like a campaign but there's
mega is just a statement that means make
america great again so i don't
understand why he's trying to create a
political assessment out of that this is
what's this is what's happening and uh
we'll i'll i'll i'll say it early just
for you john civil war okay now hold on
i'll explain
this leak from the initial drafts
never happened before that a draft was
leaked like this there was a meme post
from some leftist guy that had like 20
000 retweets or some huge number and he
was saying that his law professor told
him
this is an egregious violation of the
court and the integrity of the court and
he was like i responded taking away
women's rights is a worse scandal
and the professor said i'm not talking
about politics i'm talking about for the
courts and what they need to do
and then the person responded women are
losing their rights across this country
and you're worried about this and i'm
just like i don't look
if the if the people who are supposed to
be coming into the courts
do not care for the process of law the
process of justice then you're going to
have
psychotic activists saying
precedent law and the fabric of this
nation doesn't matter what matters is
what i think is right
so you ca
those kind of people in courts you're
going to go into court and be like i
didn't break the law the law says i'm
allowed free speech there's no laws and
i can't say naughty words and he goes i
don't care
prison that's what you end up getting
you get activist judges like who was it
was it um
wasn't was it soda mayor no no was it
kagan one of the supreme court justices
who said that uh i don't understand why
the federal mayor yeah which like i
don't understand why the states would
have this power not the federal
government or something like that
and everyone was just like screams in
1910 yeah right yeah
it's like you're a supreme court justin
you don't know these things so we i can
rag but i'll tell you what's happening
to go back with why joe biden said maga
is the most extreme
if you put out an article or or a
rallying cry
that says donald trump is racist
it will not work again you've got to up
the ante so the next day he's the worst
racist you can't say that again you got
up the ante the next day you say he's
almost as bad as hitler you can't say it
again so the next day he is as bad the
next day he's worse than
you have to keep escalating it because
people want that fix of anger and hatred
and they need a reason to hate and be
angry
so joe biden comes out and he needs a
way to rile people up for
the midterms
the roe v wade thing leaks and he says
they're the most extreme organization in
american history and you know you know
what he's doing he's targeting 18 year
olds
18 year olds who don't know about the
weather underground who don't know about
m19 ceo who don't know about these
bombings who don't even know about joe
biden
because we've had these leftists on the
show and they're like i don't know
anything about by to noah's
administration or what he did with obama
and i'm like well they blipped kids but
they don't know that he says it may 19 i
don't know nothing about no m19 m19 co
it's uh the may 19th communist
organization
so here's what's gonna happen
right now i think the one thing that's
preventing just balls to the wall chaos
and violence boomers
boomers were 30 years old or so in the
90s and they they they were the
political faction that overlapped
democrat republican to this day it is
still mostly true we had a boomer on the
show recently we talked to her and she
didn't know anything about what was
going on with our generation's politics
when the boomers age out retiring
exiting politics and or passing on
that tether is gone and you're going to
have millennials who are very much at
odds in the culture where i mean look at
where we are compared where the young
turks are
but it's it's all screaming at each
other
but we do have young people and there
are some older people involved get me
wrong boomers are involved but they're
overtly fighting in the streets what
happens when gen z and jen alpha are
raised
in a world dominated by millennial world
view which is hyper-polarized what
happens in the next generation comes in
raised by millennials millennials are
going to have kids
gen z is going to have kids and their
kids are going to be raised in those
ideologies completely bifurcated
politics in this country
that's when
chaos happens the one thing that i think
is is missing from all of the
discussions about escalation of violence
and hyperpolarization in this country is
how demographics shape what's going to
happen in this country
if in the 2000s conservatives were
having more kids than liberals then by
2020 you would have a generation that
was slightly more conservative surprise
surprise we literally have that only
slightly though the left doesn't have
kids they have your kids so as long as
they're in schools indoctrinating now
you've got millennial
conservatives and
you know xenial i guess necessarily gen
x because they're a little older
but people in their 40s and down to
millennial are fighting in these schools
and complaining about it you do have
some boomers involve some more
generation stuff
they're fighting about the
indoctrination the indoctrination is
likely going to stop because of the
culture wars or at least i believe it
will the left is going to react revolt
the one thing that may happen is if they
can't indoctrinate conservative kids
then leftism just fizzles out because
these these people i mean let's be real
they don't have kids if they get
pregnant they abort their babies and
they are actually moving towards
sterilizing or at least permanently
damaging damaging the reproductive
organs of their children mathematically
it just stands to reason 20 years from
now
it's gonna be two to one conservative in
this country yeah but that's assuming
that they don't have your kids that's
the thing about horizontal gene
translation there's there's vertical
gene translation which is parent to
child then there's horizontal which is
your environment changes your genetics
and if you have enough kids getting
brainwashed with tv where they're being
told they're transgender they're being
told they're evil or wrong that's they
could very well become that daily one
memes versus genes the entire education
system is leftist
um and then you also have culture and
people on social media telling you how
to be left to be cool or else you get
cancelled if you're an impressionable
teenager you're going to respond to
those things
but uh not if you're a french teenager
apparently one of the interesting things
i've noticed from the recent uh french
election was that uh
the younger people in france tend to be
more supportive of the right there which
is an interesting contrast with america
but this
uh
i know i think that tracks exactly with
you know what we're talking about that
the in the 2000s conservatives were
having slightly more kids than liberals
20 years that means someone who was born
in in 2000 they're 22 years old they're
voting and they're more likely to be
conservative because conservatives had
more kids that's it it doesn't matter if
you win the culture war it doesn't
matter if uh you've been effective in
your persuasion
to start the most influential element is
the parents that's why they're going for
schools they need to they need to cut
the parents out because they know
parents are more conservative than they
are
right and i think the white pill in all
this is we do seem to see a movement
pushing back against this indoctrination
i think that's what the virginia
governor's race last year was all about
and you know the the thing here that i
see is that i don't really see when we
talk about civil war
which is always a fun topic to me it
seems like conservatives won't ever be
the instigators but but progressives
leftists woke up woke people will
and so it's really critical i think for
us to uh you know to take back power to
be willing to use the government to to
shut down some of these institutions
that are trying to do this
indoctrination um to really go after him
and so that's that's like one of the
biggest debates on the right right now
is like are we going to continue to be
this like small government party that
lets schools do whatever they want to
your kids or are we going to take a more
active role and say no absolutely not
parents should have some control over
that yeah the meme works both directions
works in multiple directions you may
have indoctrination towards one thing
but just this show having you you
listening to this right now are you are
being indoctrinated
this is the part of the conversation and
if you want your kids to learn this kind
of information let them listen to this
kind of conversation it works and so we
can we can heal the earth and we can
heal our minds and our children's you
know forethought
proactively by by exposing kids to good
ideas and this is why for me it all
comes back to internet censorship i
think this is the most important issue
for all of these culture war topics
because if you control the flow if you
can't control the flow of information
then you can't indoctrinate people i
remember being in college and you know
hearing absolute nonsense from uh from
gender studies professors and things and
thinking that sounds a bit
weird i'm gonna go and look things up on
the internet see what the internet has
to say about this particular debate
about the social construction of gender
and then i'd find threads on 4chan and
reddit that breaks it that broke it all
down and explained and explained to me
that yes i was absolutely correct you
are listening to nonsense right now
here's the facts here's the data
um so it comes back to internet
censorship if you think this is why
they're so fixated on it this is why
they're so determined to stop elon musk
bringing free speech back to twitter if
they can't if they can't control those
choke points of information
uh the indoctrination machine completely
collapses and as as these left-wing
institutions you know really the clown
themselves i think people are the media
for example you look cnn's ratings
msnbc's ratings always going down uh you
know some of these things i think people
realize okay these institutions are bad
but as allen said like if you take away
our ability to access information take
away our ability to
go to the daily wire or go to some of
these other institutions to kind of
counter this programming then you know
people are going to say well i i heard
that trump's a racist i guess that's
true because that's the only source that
they they saw they're losing
i hear it more and more and and you know
the craziest thing to me actually is
having people say things like you know i
started watching your videos and then i
kind of realized about all the lies
and it's just it's really fascinating
because we have been doing this now for
for a little while but it's not just
it's it's about you know steven crowder
it's about even people like jimmy dore
you know who's a leftist but who are
challenging the establishment it's about
breaking points with crystal and sagar
these more and more people are rising up
doing shows just saying no to the
manipulation and the lies so it'll be
it'll be fascinating when these
institutions lose their power but let's
let's talk about your article allen we
have the story from breitbart
legion of doom 26 leftist ngos team up
to stop elon musk from changing twitter
alan what's this all about
so the left as you all know been
freaking out non-stop for the past uh
two or three weeks because of elon musk
who calls himself a free speech
absolutist and his plans to bring free
speech absolutism back to twitter which
is the correct way of explaining it free
speech was originally an ideal of
twitter
they changed that elon musk wants to
take them back to their roots what is
this and they can't let that happen
because who's this old guy uh i've never
seen that guy before who is he that's a
good question
that's uh yeah that's uh jack dorsey
jack dorsey that's the old ceo of
twitter
jack dorsey
wait are we allowed to say that i
thought that was like an anti-semitic
thing to even say his name isn't george
soros
remember when um newt gingrich i think
it was who was it they mentioned george
soros on fox and fox was like no
yeah and he was like what he said george
soros was funding da's like no no we
don't talk about that and he was like
but he is like
i don't understand like it's not a
secret
yeah so so he's funding a lot of these
organizations what's going on he is uh
so are some foreign governments
so uh some foreign governments are
funding these organizations uh the
government of sweden the government of
canada denmark
uh the netherlands
foreign interference in our elections
yep indeed heavens foreign manipulation
of science i can't believe this there's
no way the left would be that
hypocritical next your talent you're
gonna tell me that the left is
advocating for using horse medicine to
induce abortions
oh wait they are
this is part of what make it up when i
think people is upset maybe not
obsession with nationalism but like
adherence to nationalism worries me
because it's like
let's be realistic we're on a global
stage now everything is global there is
no more i mean there is still united
states constitution but the united
states is permeable everything is here
we're all interacting with each other at
this point
this is this is literally what jack
dorsey was saying on on rogan he was
like well we're making rules for i think
it was actually vagina we're making
rules for our global community and i'm
like this is america
this is america we got american law here
you don't silence someone for some some
other country what are you talking about
yeah and that's that's all elon musk has
said he said he uh wants free speech on
twitter to go as far as the law and no
further that's a very reasonable
position and he said people can change
the law he's like if they don't like it
they gotta change they can change the
law you can well you remember when uh
when there was a debate as to whether
this acquisition would take place uh
saudi prince came out and said you know
they had a huge stake in twitter and
they were like absolutely not the reason
is because they need to be able to
censor their own citizens and their own
citizens are using twitter i love this
take a look at this the full list
includes free press
ah yes the free press
um you may remember them from such
campaigns like stop people from having
free press yeah
what
is this freepress.net classic is that
who that is i think it's the same one
yeah cause i want to give a shout out to
freepress.net because i know some of the
people who used to work there and i
remember you know back during occupy
when they were very much like free press
free speech
until
donald trump got elected and then they
were like we should ban speech and i i
remember talking to this guy and i was
like dude
how i i hung out with him and then a few
months later he was advocating for
banning alex jones and then i was like i
thought you were the free press and he
was like but this is hate speech i'm
like when did you guys start deciding
that certain things weren't free press
anymore like i don't i don't get it
dude i i pulled up their organization on
the wayback machine
and it was like we believe in free
speech in the free press and then you
look at some point all of a sudden it's
like diversity and equity are our core
values and i'm like that's not free
press right yo they lost it you you go
back and you look at the way the left
and the liberals used to write about
twitter used to write about social media
they used to praise them for free speech
they used to praise them for opening up
communications for democratizing the
news until trump wins yeah trump's all
great until trump wins and that's weird
and they realized and they realized how
much institutional power they have and
they realized hey you know we can
prevent trump from winning again let's
exert it and now they're just full-blown
left fascists i mean that's just where
they even used to praise data mining for
elections this is fantastic article
maybe we can put it up it's called you
can probably google it you'll find it
it's called obama facebook and the power
of friendship this is the way they were
writing about the way facebook data was
used in 2012
from the guardian yes
obama facebook and the power of
friendship the power
data election
but then
donald trump did
the same thing actually i don't even
think he did i i do i do think because i
read a lot about the cambridge stuff
yeah he did far less than this i think
it's all i'll be yes facebook gave the
obama campaign their entire social graph
like cambridge analytica was nothing
compared to what facebook did in 2012.
and i think a lot of i think they
overhyped what cambridge was actually
doing oh absolutely absolutely because
like
they can't you know whatever let them
lose
these are people who
can't admit to themselves that they suck
and so it's like they're at a party
they've got you know dog crap all over
their boots and no one will go near them
and they're like it's because i'm too
cool
you know the real problem is
russia russia's telling everybody not to
hang out with me dude rush is so lame
that's what they're doing it's like no
you suck hillary was terrible why would
you run hillary clinton and they did and
it's funny because yo if they picked
literally anybody else trump would not
have won
like they went with one of the least
popular persons yeah bernie sanders
would have beat him for sure yeah i
definitely think bernie sanders would
have won but i think they could have
found like
you could have taken any any moderate
democrat
joe biden probably would that's true in
2016. but i guess because of his son is
why he didn't run they they had planned
for joe biden to run oh
hillary was just next in line she was
gonna get it she was not gonna happen
that's very regime and yeah anyone who
got in her way you know
that's crazy metaphorically
metaphorically of course the dnc just
chooses the candidate like that's really
crazy yeah the super delegates and all
that i mean that's what they did did you
guys see the meme the twitter account
roe v wade says i have information that
will lead to the arrest
of hillary
anything gets cancelled shut down ends
like a burger shop can go out of
business and someone will make a meme
about hillary clinton i think what what
gets me about this one and i think i'm
trying to see that point of view the
other point of view here is that trump
can go on stage and be like the sky is
not blue
the sky is red
this i heard the sky is red and then a
bunch of people will go online they'll
be like the sky actually is red and
people be like okay there are such thing
as cult worshipers that believe anything
even if it's not real when they hear it
from the occultist when they're called
by so people are afraid of that and they
want to censor it i think it's backwards
i think he's a very powerful speaker and
people believe him
reads a story about some potential
medications that was published in
techcrunch
because i know because i read the news
two days later donald trump goes did you
hear the news about this thing it sounds
very great there's a medication we're
we're very excited for this and then the
media all of a sudden flips and is like
no it's all bad donald trump is
dangerous and i'm like but you reported
on these studies donald trump had a
tendency of watching cable tv putting
too much stock in these institutional
news outlets because he kept giving him
interviews believing them but then the
next day they'd be like actually the
thing we said yesterday is gone here's a
good example politico reported
that ukraine meddled in the 2016
election and then when donald trump and
trump's reporter started complaining
about it politico then reported that
ukraine did not meddle in the i'm like
good stuff are you have you retracted
the initial report yet no
okay you know what man
and so that's actually you know to your
point i think what's happening in
reverse we can point this out that
politico you know basically made
something up and we're able to do that
in the digital public square and correct
people and help them come to the truth
and so with your point if if this was a
good faith argument that they were
making it's actually better for them to
say the sky is red out in the public
square because we'll be able to correct
them and guide them to where the truth
is unfortunately what they're doing is
they're they're suppressing it and so
you're going to have two americans yeah
that's where it's an overreaction let's
just let's just let's
but it could very well be because it's
intentional because i know there are
many people who want to share this show
and share the show with people who are
not initiated in the past several years
of politics here is an article from
politico in 2017 uh january of 2017 from
ken vogel and david stern ukrainian
efforts to sabotage trump backfire
ukrainian government officials tried to
help hillary clinton and undermine trump
by publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aid in
corruption and suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
clinton allies research damaging
information on trump and his advisors a
political investigation found
they never retracted this this is
damning evidence this is a story that
came out
right after the election that is still
there that has never been retracted but
yes politico and every other outlet came
out
my favorite moment shout out david
pakman when he did a segment about meet
the press asking ted cruz do you think
ukraine meddled in the election and
ted's like it was reported by politico
and like nbc and then a guy in the
background starts laughing
so like it's super unprofessional and
pac-man is like wow they're laughing at
him and i'm like david did you google
the story he they don't do it they live
in crackpot fake news reality where i
can at least say this maybe ukraine did
not meddle in the election maybe
but politico's report both they did and
they didn't so you tell me what's true i
bet they all did at this point it's a
global game and the united states is the
leader so everyone involved everyone's
involved that possibly can but it's it's
good if there's global meddling to help
the democrats it's only bad if it helps
the republicans um i mean that's their
perspective like honestly one thing that
hurts me about what you just said tim is
that you said did they google it and
we're talking about censorship and who
controls the gateway of what you can see
at google so like did you google it does
it even matter if google can decide
what's going to be on the google search
results i don't like using google's verb
think of it as a company that has a
search algorithm that is very hidden
from view i use brave as my search well
the fact is that people don't do the
barest amount of research before they
talk about anything including this if
someone like david pac-man can just be
like oh my gosh you're laughing at him
that must mean it's crazy right no it's
actually not and if you looked into it
you'd know it it's like one of the first
things to wrap up what i was saying
trump will say something whether it's
true or not people and then people may
or may not believe it they're afraid
that the cultists will believe him at
face value and that's dangerous so they
try and suppress it but i think also
that there's like trump wasn't part of
the liberal economic order he didn't
want american military supremacy all
over the earth and they didn't like that
so now they're going far beyond like hey
this guy's dangerously corrupting people
too this guy's impeding our agenda so
let's make sure that we smash him in the
press
that's the vibe i'm getting from it
and i'm tired of it so we're building
decentralized free software which will
be agpl where you can run your own
network and have your own server and
interact with other people using the
software try and bypass this stuff i'm
still concerned with verizon having isps
and things like that we've got to figure
out a way to like use decentralized tech
like noster and ostr stuff like that
where we don't need an internet to
interact with each other it's all meshed
web look at this look at this politico
ukraine ukraine ukraine when russian
disinformation met a trump obsession the
kremlin may have been laying the
groundwork for blaming ukraine for 2016
as early as 2015. oh my gosh what are
you crazy three weeks after election day
2016 the kremlin kremlin officially
floated a theory that would ultimately
lead to only the third presidential
impeachment in us history ukraine
seriously complicated the work of
trump's election by planting information
aimed at damaging his campaign chairman
paul manafort a spokesman for russians
russia's foreign ministry told reporters
on november 30th 2016 accusing the
ukrainian government of scheming to help
elect hillary clinton this is the euro
my dan just fascinating just so
fascinating that politico reported that
politico was russian disinformation
okay
okay so look i'll say this maybe it is
maybe politico really is russian
disinformation good job politico why did
you not retract the initial article then
if you're gonna publish a story claiming
it was russian disinformation that
ukraine meddled retract your own story
and apologize you are fake news
fake news
this is also concerning because there
was the government basically there's a
revolution in the ukraine in 2014 you
know the i don't know if the cia was
involved in it but that's what i i've
heard that a bunch i i can't bear 100
backed by western uh western
intelligence like i don't think that's
even in dispute anymore and so if that's
the government that was meddling to keep
trump out of office it doesn't surprise
me my thing about the whole ukraine war
right now is the us and the west was
using soft power to win over ukraine
that's what they were doing it's better
than kinetic warfare russia is being
terrible at what they do and not
understanding how to compete in fourth
and fifth generation fifth generation
fifth generation warfare decides just
going with bombs and tanks killing
people and destroying a country so
i don't like what the us was doing when
they do these manipulation campaigns but
i think the reality of the world is that
everything is influence puddling china's
going for the you know the was it the
belt and road initiative or whatever
they're going and they're offering money
the u.s going to ukraine to be like
we're going to give you a billion
dollars we're going to give you all this
stuff get us what we want i'm like okay
welcome to global politics joe biden
going in and being like fire the
prosecutor are you not getting the
billion dollars joe biden should be in
prison for that
but you know i think russia is wrong it
seems like the liberal economic order is
the borg and that the russian that
confederation federation is the klingons
like they're just brute brute force yeah
the right russian soft power like really
is pitiful compared to the us all these
myths about you know the kgb and their
uh you know
in
insane covert abilities i mean they
weren't able to stop a coup happening on
a country right in their border
uh u.s soft power really is unparalleled
even compared to china's i would say
although china's catching up
it's it's tough because
i don't like war i don't like
conflict and violence and bombs and
nukes and all that stuff
but if if it's like if the line is that
the u.s goes to countries and they're
like we're gonna give you a bunch of
money to side with us i'm like isn't
that better in terms of global interests
to like at least
sort of trade kind of you get look at
the economic the confessions of an
economic hitman he wrote about that they
come in and they offer money and then
but if you say no that's when the
problem begins because then they're like
okay now we gotta send this this is my
point of jackals here's the thing with
ukraine though you're kind of asking for
trouble if you do that to a country on
the borders of a great power estonia and
latvia are nato countries on the border
of russia i think the issue is that
russia needs the warm water port with
with crimea and so
that's a big issue for russia the u.s is
encroaching and i think russia is one of
the next dominoes to fall so russia
probably tolerated estonia and latvia
with ukraine they were like ukraine goes
in 20 years we go you take a look at
what happened with those instagrammers
from russia crying no don't ban me
russia already lost the culture war or i
should say they're losing it and now
they're trying to reverse it but man are
they late
their their children were being
indoctrinated by western social media
and so they were freaking out when
russia declared this war
i'm telling you man the difference
between boomers and even millennials and
down this gap in internet usage
people like putin and his advisors his
military guys they don't understand the
the cultural and mental world view
difference they have from their kids
because their kids weren't raised by
them their kids were raised by the
internet and they were being raised by
facebook
face cia book as the activists like to
call it
so what happens after vladimir putin
ages out as it were you can't spell
facial without cia
this is one of the big reasons why the
establishment was praising facebook and
twitter and social media for their free
speech before trump because i think
there was there was a uh a chap who
worked in the trump administration an
appointee uh i won't name him who said
uh the uh and this was like you
follows for the foreign policy part of
the deep state very closely he said um
the u.s establishment the defense
establishment liked social media because
it helped them do regime change abroad
but then with 2016 and brexit they
realized oh no can regime change the
west
that's what i'm wondering it's like it's
like we're in an avalanche this whole
globalizing internet culture
and how we can't stop the avalanche i
mean i can't fathom that so we just got
to ski the avalanche i mean at this
point build technology like yeah open
source free software and it's hard even
for companies like google and twitter
and facebook uh to do it because these
are all started as open platforms so you
still can find articles and your videos
debunking this political stuff if with
enough creative google searches you
could find it on twitter going viral uh
they they haven't been able to censor
these these uh platforms completely
because these platforms were not made to
be censored which is why the left is
furious with them i mean the left wants
total control here that's where you know
as much from the right we see big tech
as being sensorious and terrible and all
that and they have been the left wants
them to double down triple down i mean
it's absolutely insane i mean you know
my entire job is is exposing big tech
but if we're talking about the uh the
regime
big tech is
not entirely a reluctant partner but
they have they they were pressured into
it
to a large degree by external forces
especially the media
and this is why we see these 26
organizations coming and saying we need
an advertiser boycott of twitter because
that's their leverage over the tech
companies ultimately that's how they get
them to do things yeah you know what
elon musk was trying to get away from
ads anyway
he knows exactly what he's doing he's
thought about this
he wants to do a subscription membership
model he wants to charge for premium
access and i think it's a brilliant idea
and i'll i will i'll be totally honest
uh i got a lot of followers on twitter
if they came to me and said we've got a
premium suite i'd be like done yes
show me like show me data
on uh there's like there's the analytics
sucks for twitter give me like a premium
analytics suite
i don't i don't care about twitter
because you can't use it the way you can
use say youtube youtube tells me here's
how many people watched your video in
the first hour here's how many people
like how long they watched your first
video and i'm like oh okay so here's
what they like here's what they don't
like twitter is like say something and
cross your fingers
if they actually came out and said for x
amount of dollars we'll do this for you
i think they should be verifying
everybody
i think you know i guess elon musk said
he wants what like two bucks um two
bucks per month for twitter blue and
then they'll verify you though your
identity and all that stuff not everyone
has to be identify identified not
everybody has to be verified
people will still be able to use it for
free and i'm like i think he's got a
good plan for this
and he's he's so smart i mean i i know
he made comments about this isn't about
economics which is great like i'm glad
that he's doing this for for free speech
but he's too smart for that like he
knows that he paid 44 billion dollars
he's got web 3 ideas he's got
decentralization ideas he's got all
sorts of things well sure i'm sure he
will turn this into a trillion dollar
company i would bet my this that
everything i'm not sure he has web 3
ideas he constantly uh constantly dunks
on web3 projects uh which which to be
fair a lot of them are a bit
bad yeah shout out to hive in the
recovery of the steam network i think
elon in this situation is a student he's
been the master at all his other
companies because he started them this
one he bought so he's here to learn how
cool would it be if after elon buys
twitter one day everyone wakes up and
when they log in they just see
when they log into their account it's
just geocities
and there's like
just like the banana guy the peanut
butter jelly time you know gifs and all
that stuff and people like wait what's
going on and elon's like the internet
was better back when we just did it this
way so now twitter is this and it's like
just you're reminding me of uh ytm nds
remember those i remember those
those were those were 4chan before
fortune that was amazing
you guys ever go on newgrounds oh yeah
back in the day that's crazy
newgrounds.com for those that don't know
was youtube before youtube existed and
they missed the train they had time they
yeah they had flash video because they
were cartoon oriented and so what
happened was i could be totally wrong
about this um i used to i was on new
grounds every day looking at every new
submission these were people were
uploading cartoons they decided to do
flash animation stuff
and then i remember when youtube came
around and then all of a sudden the
animators started putting their stuff on
youtube because
it was just easy and fast
new grounds could have done video in
fact they had some video sometimes but i
i guess they thought no no we're an
animator community so we're going to
stick to that and then everyone migrated
their animations to youtube and that was
and they probably were they were so big
they didn't see the threat coming but
it's but the crazy thing is they were so
big but nowhere near as big as youtube
came to be
do you remember the ultimate showdown i
was i was of course i was nine i thought
it was the funniest [ __ ] ever imagine if
right now we were streaming not on
youtube but on new grounds because they
they had
flash player they they could have done
video imagine if they built out that
infrastructure we'd be in a very
different place i wonder what what they
would do because a lot of the content
they posted is just adult humor like not
for kids
yeah could you comment on videos on new
grounds yeah yeah yeah of course youtube
had those video responses which really
enlivened the community before google
bought them i wonder if google was
planning on buying them before that or
if they were like whoa there's a
community here and we want to build
communities so we're going to buy it but
they bought it for a billion and youtube
was dying was like they couldn't pay for
their their infrastructure so they had
to sell the company that's what it what
it came to let's let's talk about what's
going on with will chamberlain because
as we talk about our cultural decay and
our institutional collapse will
chamberlain has tweeted out a law clerk
by the name of elizabeth deutsch
he says in his humble opinion she's the
most likely person to have leaked the
draft supreme court opinion in dobbs
purporting to overturn roe v wade he
says a disclaimer i have no inside
information this threat is speculation
based almost entirely on publicly
available information i could easily be
wrong
now
apparently he's being threatened that
he's going to get sued over this which
is just laughably stupid elizabeth
deutsch is arguably not a public figure
but guess what people can become public
figures
whoa
now
will prefaces he doesn't know for sure
it's a speculation and you're allowed to
speculate and will is also a lawyer so i
think he knows what he's doing but i i
think this is this is a really
interesting thread because of how the
reaction has been let me see if i have
this one from eric swalwell eric
swalwell you know you love me farted on
tv he said under supreme court law as a
public figure i take a lot of defamatory
attacks because bar is too high to sue
miss deutsche is not a public figure and
would likely have a strong defamation
case against will chamberlain
republicans are bullies but they always
back down when challenged ron coleman
says you are not scaring anyone but you
are getting some some of us pretty
excited
and then it's elmer fudd saying i love
civil litigation
okay okay so here's here's the gist i'll
just give you the simple version she is
um according to this threat from will
she's an uh like a reproductive rights
activist is that what they how they call
it
her academic background isn't uncommon
he says things get interesting every law
student has to write a note a long legal
research paper making a novel argument
about the law hers is about reproductive
rights and abortion she argued that
obamacare's non-discrimination provision
should be interpreted to force catholic
hospitals to perform emergency abortions
aggressive argument but hey law students
are aggressive he says while in law
school she wrote a new york times op-ed
about reproductive rights her career
page on linkedin doesn't reveal that
much until we dig a little further
thanks to her new york times wedding
announcement of course we know that she
clerked for judge nina pillard pillard
was one of the dc circuit judges
appointed by obama and forced through by
harry reid to blow up the filibuster
she's stridently pro-choice perhaps not
shocking after her clerkship she got a
gruber fellowship at the aclu for a full
year working on abortion and
reproductive rights
none of this proves anything deutsch's
career seems pretty focused on abortion
but without some connection to josh
gerstein the journalist who received the
leak there would be no reason to suspect
her
let's go back to that new york times
wedding announcement the bride and groom
she met at yale she is a lawyer he is a
journalist
isaac arnsdorff just got hired by the
washington post as a national political
reporter of course he's on the trump
beat
but he but where has he written in the
past politico sharing a byline with josh
gerstein interesting uh so that's that's
that's the connection says uh looks like
gerson and they are still bros chatting
on twitter interacting as recently as
last year to conclude we have a
currently setting supreme court law
clerk whose career has been almost
solely focused on abortion she wrote a
law school note on abortion short op-eds
about reproductive rights spent a year
working on abortion at the aclu clerked
for a pro-choice judge and just so
happens that her husband is a journalist
sharing bylines with josh gerstein at
politico and it looks like they're still
friends sharing a byline means they
worked together like they they've shared
this story that's published so they know
each other for sure he says i don't know
that elizabeth deutsch leaked the draft
opinion but i certainly think someone
who has spent much of their academic and
professional life fighting to expand the
right to get an abortion could be
desperate enough to do so
i think it's a uh an interesting thread
and some good journalistic journalistic
work he didn't publish any private
details outside of here's a person who
publicly works for the court and we're
looking for a leaker robbie suave says
what is the argument that it's okay to
do this but not to reveal the name of
libs of tick-tock
ian miles trung she's not anonymous for
one and secondly will didn't publish
deutsche's home address she's not
anonymous she's literally a law clerk
someone leaked the information we are
going to start looking who the publicly
available information on law clerk says
libs of tick tock's name was not in in
the public but my argument on that one
was always i disagree with it but
there's an argument to be made about the
journalistic um
issue around whether or not someone's
who someone is is is uh should be public
knowledge considering libs of tik-tok
had 600 000 followers and was
influencing politics i think the
reporting was warranted but the name
didn't serve a purpose posting the home
address was crossing the line as for
this this is not an anonymous person
this is someone who has stamped law
clerk at the supreme court under their
name
all of this is in the press
libs of tick tock's information may have
been public as they argue but it was in
like registries it was in like real
estate licenses there was nothing saying
linkedin person libs of tick tock like
this individual has now they're
threatening to sue i wonder if will is
over target on this one and he actually
found who may have leaked the also
making popular beams on twitter and not
even making popular means sharing videos
on twitter of other people of other
people and
being at the highest court in the land
that those are like two different
categories of power
oh yeah posting memes is way more
powerful
i'm sorry i just don't buy that this
isn't a public person you know you work
for a member of congress that's publicly
known um you know if you tweet something
as a member of congress i guarantee you
the new york times or whoever will will
go after you so you know i think look
will is a incredibly smart guy he's very
careful i imagine he went through all of
these clerks and kind of did some
process of elimination and uh look i
mean this is really interesting you know
the media is not going to do anything
about this right they're not going to
look for the leaker they're happy it
happens so oh yeah i think it's going to
have to be on on people like will and
other sleuths too this is the media as
well and so that's part of how we're
changing what the media is right we're
so used to being on the app being
outside of the building looking in that
the media usually refers to the
establishment but
we're we're taking over we're taking
that space so the corporate press i
think is usually even this is corporate
press this is this is not team cast as a
corporation that's not where we're
usurping that title the bad i mean
this is
um you know what's been crossing my mind
that it's a spouse somebody talked to
their spouse it's so easy to go home
after work and lay in bed all stressed
out and just blab about what you did at
the job so it's very well could have
been still they'd still have to get it
they had the physical 98-page draft
and apparently that's really limited in
terms of who could have i'm not saying
that i don't know what this is tons of
journalists are married to people in
politics yeah it is one thing it is not
the the was the the fourth estate i
think the press was supposed to be yeah
yeah no the fourth estate and what's the
the third estate is that which one which
is it is the third state government i
think it's the third oh whatever
whichever whichever estate is supposed
to be you know unlike the
representatives has merged with
journalism and now it's
paulism now it's a monopoly of states a
monopoly of estates
here's the here's got another tweet mike
sternovich you said new talking point
just went out doesn't matter who leaked
adam schiff says i don't care how the
draft leaked that's a side show what i
care about is that a small number of
conservative justices who lied about
their plans to the senate intend to
deprive millions of women of
reproductive care codifying rho isn't
enough we must expand the court
oh incredible so a leak from the supreme
court is a sideshow this is this is an
interesting precedent how many more
leaks from the supreme court are going
to happen in the future now when some
progressive clerk doesn't like what she
sees these i'm telling you man
boomers
had scruples
i asked this question why is there why
can't you bribe a cop in the united
states
because the cop will arrest you on the
spot but why can you bribe a cop in
russia
it's still illegal to do
but there's no scruples they're not
worried about repercussions they're not
worried about being ostracized or
cancelled or anything like that
for the older generations they're
genuinely worried that if i step out of
line people will be mad at me
now you've got these law clerks were
like i literally don't care
what anyone else thinks my tribe must
win
when you have two distinct political
factions and within those umbrellas you
have many different ideologies like
libertarian and conservative are kind of
in the same space but they really don't
agree with each other just like
progressives and neolibs don't but
they're in the same space
what happens is we had one united states
and a republican would be like
i can't do that because
democrats you know i'm going to get all
the flack from my colleagues in congress
that one goes too far
nowadays there it's basically come to
the point where left and right says i do
not care at all what the right things
the left must get this thing
so
the attitude now with cancel culture
um ethan klein really great example h3h3
he makes an offensive statement he
apologizes to his fans we all laugh and
be like look what you have to do but to
him he's like i don't care about the
right things because the right's not
paying my bills so i'll apologize if i
have to
that's where that's where we're at right
now there's no ethan can come out and
accuse anyone on the right of being
anything and there's zero there's zero
damage he will face
we had a d transitioner on the show
yesterday and i'm like i'm sure a bunch
of activists are gonna come and scream
in my face but they have zero impact on
my work or my show so why should i care
and that means when the boomers are gone
there's going to be two distinct
political realities in this country you
said that there's one united states i
see 50 united states and the reason we
have 50 states is because just in case a
political faction attempts to cease
power at the federal level the states
have total recourse to resist that and
that means civil war or just means a
revolution no because
california will not tolerate a
republican revolution if the right goes
in the federal government and takes over
california says no i don't think it has
to be a political revolution a
technological revolution
dude
a revolution of states the the issue the
issue with this is you know republicans
conservatives will always say federalism
will solve everything that we should we
should push things back to the states
but i do think you know it's important
to know who our enemy is here and to
tim's point i mean these are people who
think that the ends are always justified
and so
you know
why why would california listen to you
know something so i i'll i'll take a
different view here i think the most
important was the information war
and the reason why these divides are
happening is because the media has gone
so far to the left that is creating this
alternative reality
yes yes but uh well have you guys
i disagree a little bit i think social
media created a generation living in a
broken fractured world where there is no
truth but power
and then they got jobs in media and now
the new york times is being worn as a
skin suit as is the washington post
i mean look yeah kids using facebook
when they're 14 and they figured out how
to go viral now they're working in the
journal now they're at the new york
times sort of it was
news organizations funded by venture
capital who found the fastest path
towards making money was rage bait and
so you ended up with websites like
mike.com which initially started as ron
paul supporting and then went woke
because they were like this stuff works
you know what doesn't work for the right
what worked for the right was anti-sjw
we don't like the things they're doing
so we're going to complain about it
whenever they do it
what worked for the left was literally
lying about anything
it's claiming that cops are going around
hunting down black people russiagate
covington justice millet ghost of kiev
that's a new one michael brown trayvon
martin ahmed arbory lie lie lie lie lie
like kyle written now sly they do it
nonstop all day every day and it works
every time these people live in a
chaotic dimension of flame fire and
destruction and they don't care they've
been wrong about almost every major
cultural story of the past decade they
don't care you will not change their
minds so when i pull up politico quite
literally having two articles one saying
ukraine did meddle and one saying
actually that was russian disinformation
but they never retracted the other one
how can these people exist how can their
brains function with such cognitive
dissonance that is the problem the
information war yes but if these people
are in a cult and you can't reach them
then there's going to be fighting you
can but you got to figure out how
everyone can be reached every cult
member can be reached usually got it
there's a way and it's true
the way to do it is to show them they're
not as popular as they think
and what's insulating them from that is
social media censorship what i want to
know is why are republicans so keen on
bailing this industry out bailing the
news media out the same industry that is
publishing these politico articles the
same who's trying to bail them out
uh a bunch of republican senators
apparently they've jumped onto this amy
klobuchar build called the journalism
competition
this by the way this is gonna be fun the
uh the journalism competition and
preservation act i think i've discussed
it on the show before
the um so you've probably seen all these
bills in australia and canada that force
tech companies to pay
news outlets for content this is the
american version of that it would allow
media companies to get together in a
cartel to collectively negotiate with
the tech companies on things like uh
ads things like ads and things like
uh paying them for content and uh
so which republicans are on it
well if you get it if you're and paul
yes round round paul's on this lindsey
graham cynthia llamas cynthia llamas has
also signed on to really another really
terrible book
paul you you come on this show and
explain your position on this because i
trust i like rand paul so i want to hear
what he's why he's i'll i have the
answer to why that so many republicans
are on this it's because news corp is
one of the biggest pushes of this and
republicans like news corp
did you blindly trust it or something
well you know
rupert murdoch and his media companies
have them on have them on fox news
give us give us the elevator pitch of
what the bill does it says to provide a
safe harbor for publishers online of
online content to collectively negotiate
with dominant online platforms regarding
the terms on which content may be
distributed it's a it's a temporary
waiver on antitrust to basically allow
these small publishers to collectively
bargain against facebook and google
small publishers where in the building
where the builder that says it includes
all there's a non-discrimination
provision so you like it i like the bill
i think it's a good bill so it allows to
me to me my thing is facebook and google
are the bigger enemy here and they have
absolutely destroyed local news like i
want decentralization of news i want
local newspapers to be able to report on
stuff and i think the way the model is
currently it benefits facebook and
google it's absolutely put but
the issue is
what
local news has been destroyed but it's
because
people want national stories so
it used to be that to get your news you
turn on you know channel five for the
five o'clock news i remember we had fox
32 in chicago yeah at simpsons were at
like 5 30 or something and then central
time yeah central time and then and then
at 6 00 p.m was the news and i'd go uh
and then afterwards it was seinfeld and
i was like i liked the simpsons when i
was a kid and uh that you you'd watch
your news but your news would be like
who's who's that guy on wgn is that
larry potash i don't remember he's still
there i think uh it was local stories
you'd get some national stuff but they'd
also be like a fire hydrant burst over
on the corner of 63rd and you know
california and now there's water
everywhere the road has been blocked off
and you're like
now you turn on the news at cnn and
they're like trump is a nazi and you're
like okay that's not anything relevant
to me then you go on google you type in
news you get cnn cnn's gonna give you
all national stories cbs all national
stories so you have to actively choose
as someone in an area to find your local
news but i think most people don't do
that the other thing is you know local
news is how this is being pitched to
congressman i mean anyone who's been in
politics for a long time knows that the
great soundbite is we're on the side of
the little guys against the big guys
that's how polls have been selling
almost anything for a very very long
time
there's nothing in the bill that limits
this to local news
but there is a big part of the bill that
allows any cartel that forms to exclude
whoever they want as long as they're not
similarly situated to them i don't think
that's true so there's a lot like
scripture and hold on bro you gotta have
a billion viewers
the bill says you can't have fewer than
one billion monthly active users in
aggregate i'd we'd have to look at the
language i think i think it's talking
about social media it's got to be also
i'm pretty sure that draft of the jcpa
is not the most accurate the most recent
one because there's been a lot of work
on it i've i've seen uh i've actually
seen a draft of an unreleased draft of
some amendments and it's even worse
they're going to extend it by 10 years
instead of the original four that's how
long it'll apply for plus they're going
to add something that they're going to
separate into categories one for
broadcasters which they define as
stations they don't define it as
youtubers youtubers you're not going to
get a handout because of this bill tim
no no youtuber is going to get a hand at
no podcaster no sub stack author is
going to get a handout it's all for the
legacy media it's all for paper
newspapers it's all for traditional
broadcasts they're trying to rescue them
from the internet they should not be
doing that
no it's it's a ballad it's the same
thing they're doing in canada it's the
same thing they're doing in uh in
australia and uh you know the way this
works in dc is that the news media
alliance which is the big umbrella
lobbying group for all the big media
companies uh you should check out their
website go to go to
newsmediaalliance.org
board of directors and look at some of
the people who are who are part of this
organization that basically wrote this
bill
and you're not going to see a lot of
local news in there
we need board of directors
we've got antoinette bush maribel
wadsworth pamela browning who are these
people look at their titles executive
vice president global head of government
affairs news corp president of publisher
usa today
this is very strange because like i i
just don't so so what would you suggest
what would you suggest is a better play
to prevent facebook and google from
getting all this ad revenue from
basically like incentivizing the
nationalization of everything it's free
marketing no it goes back to what we
were saying uh when we were talking
about how evil is big tech
uh big tech was pressured into censoring
by advertising workers driven by the
media
so big tech is bad but they're bad
because they are favoring the media and
this is and this is a bill that would
force them to favor the media even more
than they're currently doing what we
want is for them to allow everyone to
compete on an equal playing field not to
give massive handouts to the journalism
in it why why on earth would republicans
want there to be handouts to newspapers
even local newspapers which are just as
left as
left when yeah
i don't we don't need a handout and i
don't want my competition to get free
money from the government or for
protections if these news organizations
can't figure out how to run their
business for the modern era they
shouldn't exist look i think it's a
complicated bill i think there's a lot
of arguments on both sides on it but i
will say this which is if you're going
to take on big tech the biggest problem
conservatives have is that these
companies don't respect republicans they
don't respect them as having posing any
sort of threat whatsoever to them and so
if you're not going to embrace which
olim i know we disagree on antitrust too
but if you're not going to embrace any
sort of actual solution that'll do
something to these companies they're not
going to change their you know they're
going to continue to sense that i got
your solution that free their software
code you can't break the company apart
enough times you've got to make sure
that the code is available if you want
democratization of the network then
everyone's got to have sex
are we saying we have to sign on to
every tech regulation no but we should
offer we should offer an idea we have
all these republican members
establishment members i'm objecting to
i'm not objecting to all of the bills
john i'm going to this particular bill i
am a huge supporter of bill haggerty's
proposed tech regulation i'm a huge
supporter of texas proposed tech
regulation well yeah
we agree on section two i like the
jurisdiction bill there are lots of
bills unlike this one is a bailout is
the it's the worst it's actually i'll i
will make it closer it is the worst bill
of this congress bailing out the media
the reason where we have parents
who think it's a good idea to chemically
castrate their own children is because
the media made that idea cool the reason
why we have people supporting defunding
the police is because the media made it
into
an issue the reason why we have uh libs
of tick tock being doxed is because of
the media the reason the entire country
believed
russia was in control of the government
for a full two years is because of the
media the reason why oh yeah
children were masters schools and for
republicans that support a bill that
bails out the media that's an obscene
betrayal of their voters i think that's
a really that's a really good talking
point but i don't think if you would
talk to rand paul if you would talk to
these guys i don't think that that's
i know exactly what happened the news
corp loyal the newspaper lobbyists and
the news media alliance went and went
and spoke to them um and uh
it says any print broadcast or digital
news organization that has a dedicated
professional editorial staff that
creates and distributes original news
and related content concerning local
national or international matters of
public interest on at least a weekly
basis
and is marketed through subscriptions
advertising or sponsorship provides
original news and related content with
the editorial content consisting of
consisting of not less than 25 current
news and related content blah blah blah
blah blah blah and to mine so my
knowledge there's a more recent draft
that actually even expanded
and uh there's well the new the new one
says 1500 employees but that's that's a
trick because you can always corporate
restructure your organization to make it
into lots of little small uh
small 1500 employee chunks
um what you the thing you that the thing
you read out there tim dedicated
professional editorial stuff that leaves
out every uh one-man independent
journalist every one-man operation on
sub-sector leave that glenn greenwald
glenn green will not be covered by that
we are changed leave that lucrative
glenn greenwald went before congress and
opposed this bill for the wow for uh and
you should actually watch his testimony
before the house committee it says the
bill creates a four-year safe harbor
from anti-trust laws for print broadcast
or digital news companies to
collectively negotiate with online
content distributors requiring the terms
on which the news company's content may
just be distributed by online content
content distributors i completely oppose
that in every way
you're telling me that you think the new
york times the washington post cbs abc
nbc should be able to come together
violating anti-trust provisions to
negotiate collectively amongst all of
the biggest and most powerful media in
the world i don't think that's what it
does that's literally what i just read
well so as i said that's that's an older
text i know that they've excluded some
of the larger ones i my concern is local
news i want to make sure that we're not
having everything nationalized
same thing that you just mentioned i
mean it's like 117th congress 2022. no
no no i know there's there's okay it
hasn't been marked up there's a there's
a mark-up coming
but
the local news talking point is pure
marketing they know everyone dislikes
the big national media corporations
that's why they're talking about local
news they were marketing
this draft as far as who's going to be
able to deal with uh google and facebook
screwing them over more local news or
the big guys
i would rather how about you
destroy the media machine through
technological advancement and then
people like us figure out how to pick up
the pieces and build outside of that
ecosystem and create something new
through merit so one of the things we
did was over a year ago we launched
timcast.com we are funded primarily now
through memberships we are we are we are
removing our reliance on big tech
platforms and we have been reducing our
reliance on big tech platforms the next
thing we're going to be doing is doing
mobile apps and tv smart tv apps we are
finding a way to navigate this we've got
infrastructure being built right now to
make us more sensor resilient and i do
not want to see cnn team up with the
washington post in the new york times to
give themselves more power by leveraging
the weight of their massive
conglomeration against facebook and
google leaving all of us holding an
empty bank and you know i was covering
this from the beginning this favoring of
the media it's the culmination of that
trend so facebook already pays billions
to news companies in licensing google
has port billy hundreds of millions if
not billions into propping up the media
already and they're doing that because
they've been told for five years by the
by the media if you don't favor us we're
going to whip up advertiser boycotts and
this is a part of that is trying to
enshrine that same trend in law the
worst trend of silicon valley promoting
the media and making what was previously
an even playing field
uneven
by the way i also want to bring up one
one uh tremendous uh tremendous little
statistic i found recently
according to gallup
as of 2021
11
of republicans have a great deal or a
fair amount of trust in the media eleven
percent
um and according to pew
the number of republicans who think
abortion should be legal in all or most
cases is 35
so the media are less popular with
republicans than abortion
wow i feel like so
maybe not being sensational enough when
i say we need to free their software
code i want to hear what you guys think
about this too i think
what these republican senators have done
is the equivalent of taking money from
planned parenthood
the free the software code ian you've
never articulated what that would do
besides just making people know what
their code is it would give you the
opportunity to make your own network you
can do that right now no you don't have
access to their code so what are you
talking about google analytics you
brought up earlier twitter doesn't have
a good analytics platform because google
has a proprietary analytic platform they
become the commons so we need to treat
it like the commons and liberate the
software
that's my argument but that's i mean i
suppose my issue with that and what most
people probably argue is you're just
talking about seizing the means of
production no i don't quite literally i
don't think so i mean
it's like there's tolls on every road
that are owned by alphabet right now we
need to get rid of those tolls bro you
can build your own analytics software
yeah but it takes
a long they how many of you yeah welcome
to the world hey if you want to i
shouldn't have to build my house you
could start your own army now
stay in your cage
like what i think what we want is very
simple if you look at what's happening
in 2016 the independent media was
eclipsing the mainstream media because
at that point google and facebook and
twitter were not favoring the mainstream
media it was a relatively even playing
field that's what we want we don't want
the news media to be protected in any
way which is in the literal title of
this bill journalism competition and
protection act and no technology
i'm liberating the means of production
yeah that's exactly what communists said
no they would take it from the state i
don't want to see the state i'm not
giving this stuff to the state i'm
giving it to humanity what do you bro
you need to read some communist
literature it's not it's not property of
anything it's just what he's saying
communist
it just it depends on what you're saying
exactly so like if you're talking about
um like data i think it's really
interesting like if if i
provide my data to facebook you're
saying code the the literal yeah like
code's a little tougher because you know
there are property rights to consider
there um
you're effectively arguing that it's too
hard to build a factory so the factory
should be open to the public to use i
don't want google's factory i'm not
seizing their headquarters it's not 20th
century time anymore it's 21st century
where digital property is a real thing
now we have to treat it like such they
built a machine that took millions of
dollars in years and you are saying well
no one else can do that it would take
too long so we should be able to have
the machine they built is server space
and they can keep their servers i'm not
talking about seizing their stuff i'm
talking about giving people access to
the information
we've had this discussion before that
you don't believe in intellectual
property rights well i mean they yeah
for sure there's intellectual proper
rights but when something functions in
the commons then you've got to start
questioning if they still have the right
to own it
right i guess the fundamental difference
is i believe in private property rights
me too but up to a certain amount of
daily active users a billion daily
active users and you own the thing that
is controlling the billion active users
like is that righteous
anymore i don't think so the website
would just be like okay we're locked at
999 million users 999 million 999
they would they might destroy their
business model just i would say they're
going to say if we get one more user we
lose our property rights because because
then if 100 million other people spin up
versions of youtube and they all
interoperate the original youtube
benefits
it has more activity on the network
you're not saying you're not making
sense i'm saying that that's not you but
i understand you don't understand no ian
you're saying that if
people if if a platform reaches a
billion users its code has to be
released to the public yeah it's an
arbitrary number but the company would
then choose to restrict their platform
to not exceed that otherwise they would
lose their right and then the company
which means they would not give out
their code and no one would spin up
their own versions because the code's
never released well you could pick a
number that's well under their then they
would say start a new company and we'll
own all five versions of it and we'll
have them as separate corporations see i
think the issue that we often see with
the leftist arguments is they don't know
how business or yeah okay so let's go
into that so google you're saying we'll
split up youtube into five companies
that each have a fifth of the daily
active users yes you think that people
aren't going to see that and and see
that they're creating some sort of in
fact they did sort of already do that
with alphabet that's what they were
trying to do core restructuring ian i
think the issue is your ideas are not
formulated based on an understanding of
how businesses we're still just an idea
yeah i'm not a lawyer so i'll give you
an example
uh taxes the left says like we should
tax the rich okay well we have taxes on
the rich they they do pay a large amount
of taxes well then why didn't elon musk
penny taxes well elon musk this year he
did pay a lot of taxes why didn't he pay
taxes in 2018 well probably because he
didn't take any money because he didn't
need to he did not need to pay himself
he's gotta he's got he eats food at the
office he his business pays for things
so he takes no personal income because
the business does what the business pays
taxes they say amazon didn't pay any
taxes actually amazon paid an insane
amount of taxes because they're not just
paying corporate income tax they're
paying employment taxes property taxes
health care all of this stuff they're
taxed very very heavily
when it comes to the arguments about how
do we then make the rich pay their fair
share it's like you've not defined what
fair share is okay well what if what if
we said they have to pay 20
it's like the rich already have a higher
tax bracket than that well then why
aren't we getting their money
there are laws in place
that make sense
once you get to a certain amount of
power those laws don't mean anything
anymore and i'll put it simply elon musk
has no reason to pay himself any money
if his business is always stocked with
food he walks in and there's a luncheon
for all the employees and he can just
eat what's there he doesn't need to buy
himself a car if the business has a car
that he drives for business reasons so
they're saying why isn't he paying taxes
because of the existing structure which
makes sense that he is using but the
taxes are happening somewhere what
you're saying and arguing about the free
the code all the time fundamentally
misunderstands how businesses work you
know what they would do they would put
their headquarters in dublin and then it
would negate anything you proposed well
i mean if they want to operate in the
states they got to follow the united
states no they don't they live they do
they also don't have to follow the first
amendment in your strange uh which is
why dangerous reality which is why i
advocate for a change to the laws to
give me your idea then so uh
nationalization or uh
but i'm the one that wants to seize the
means you're the one who wants to
nationalize the thing yeah yeah yeah i'm
trying to interrupt you but right right
right see the issue is i'm going to come
out and say that when twitter takes
control of the public space in terms of
communications we could do a
hybridization of a privately owned
public space which means the public has
a right to it but it's owned privately
and they can dictate how they run the
business to make money that's how
zuccotti parked work in new york
what you're saying is you would take
their ownership of the the the code
itself and give it to everyone else
which would
i don't think would do anything at all
to be completely honest i i think
ownership is still i'm interested in the
idea because what's the incentive for a
corporation to do this you said that a
bigger network it's like breaking up a
monopoly i don't think they would want
it it would just be it wouldn't destroy
the company that's the point it's
breaking it's giving it's re removing
the monopoly without destroying the
company so in terms of ownership i don't
think i would agree with you but in
terms of you know like
if we reformed section 230 for
the largest companies to
uh to be like a first amendment standard
or something like that and you were
trying to prove in court so you had a
private right of action in the law you
were trying to prove in court that
google was suppressing your content
there would be a discovery right a
discovery phase where you could look at
the algorithm something like that i'm
more interested in what you're talking
about if it's disclosure of like what it
is
the actual ownership i think i'd really
struggle no one owns it it's agpl3 it's
just free software the idea would be if
you spend 10 years building software
code to run a service like twitter if
they get to a certain
size
the code itself is then given to the
public who can then take all of that
reverse engine no no no no no no not
reverse engineer literally just press go
and have twatter so truth what truth
social could be twitter so yeah truth
was built off of massive i think what
was mastered yeah yeah mastodon's code
and so because it was open source
they're supposed to credit it i guess
they still haven't oh geez
but uh
i think the issue there is what we see
every time we try and take away
someone's property
no one's going to invest in building
twitter if they lose that investment
you're going to go to a person of means
and say we need a hundred thousand
dollars to build a program that does x
and they're going to say and in 10 years
where's my money oh completely gone
because everyone gets it yeah well maybe
it will know social media no longer will
be about making money maybe it's
actually going to be about public good
for once who will do that
uh bill altman at mines people that want
to make money we build free software
yeah and you can make money by selling
services related to the software does
bill of investors yeah do those
investors expect a return on their
investment i don't know it's a private
company it depends on what bill wants to
do the answer is yes no that's public
that's the public uh sure delays that
it's obsessed with making money private
companies don't have to make money you
just do your service if you want to i
think you want to stay afloat maybe if
we're talking about mission-driven
culture
where people are like i want to make a
company that does like like like tim
guest
i i know the guy who led the investment
the investment in uh mines quite well he
definitely does care about free speech
and open
open software um so that's
some investors do actually care about
that stuff no for sure does he expect to
get his money back or make money off of
it you'd have to ask him i wonder i
wonder if if you want to win the show uh
he'll be happy to come on well we have
we actually have bill coming on i think
soon yeah yeah so we'll talk about a lot
of i i think if you want to do what what
what did they launch a while ago b
corpse
that they're they're allowed to act like
i i could be wrong about this but i
someone told me once that they're
allowed to they're a corporation that
doesn't have to make money
they're like a hybrid of a non-profit
for-profit so whereas most corporations
have to make money for their
shareholders they have a fiduciary duty
i think b corps are the ones that are
like we can they're like a do good
corporation or something like that
the goal of tim cast is
it's to make money but
mostly about the mission we want to do
cool things when we have an impact
that's why we did the the times square
billboard thing i know i know people are
like we've heard about it yeah yeah the
point is
i sit back and i look at elon musk he's
buying twitter that's what i'm talking
about i sit back and i look at joe rogan
well he does his show but
i wonder does joe do anything like
challenging the establishment or the
system outside of just his show
and if not because i've not seen it i
wonder why that is this is in no way am
i saying he's obligated to do so i'm
just like where are the people of wealth
and means who are sick of all of this
standing up and being like f you they're
in this freaking room you should you
should definitely have the uh the mines
investor on the show aaron aaron wolfe
he is exactly what you're talking about
i met him in austin he's fantastic love
you erin part of the problem
unfortunately is that a lot of the
people with means have uh desires that
go against i think where we would be at
where a lot of the american people would
be at and so you know i'll tell you as
you know we're a very conservative
organization
when we've been raising money for
politics to to get involved in these
campaigns it's really hard for
conservatives especially to talk about
you know raising money to do ads on
abortion or on the trans stuff or any of
that because the donors just aren't out
there the donors are much more
interested in giving you know for uh you
know mass immigration or things like
that and so i think i think that's a
difficulty that we have i think one of
the issues is except for elon
you know my view of capitalism is
if you do good and you're effective you
will make money if you are doing
providing a service however i i don't
believe in absolute unfettered free
markets like i i don't i think you'll
end up with people doing really weird
things like
metaverse porn where people become
carrots and like that's probably going
to happen anyway and i'm like i'm pretty
libertarian on that but i do think it's
bad for society as a whole that we'll
chase after self-gratification instead
of
going to the space so i i'm a huge fan
of elon musk go to mars starship twitter
stuff starlink all really awesome stuff
i look at it like traditional idealistic
capitalism is you invent a light bulb
you illuminate the world congratulations
you'll be made rich because of it you
are being rewarded by people for saying
we appreciate your service and now you
get to live comfortably because you did
something great i think timcast.com does
really good things and i think we're
going to continue to grow and do more
good things and for it we get rewarded
for doing great things nikola tesla is
an example of someone that didn't know
how to capitalize what a brilliant
generous good man from what i know about
him and man he did not know how to write
a patent or whatever it was whereas
einstein knew how to patent his stuff
and became very very wealthy and nicola
died a pop popper like he was alone he
lived in a hotel room telling people he
had a death laser to get to stop not
have to pay for his room every night
just a tragic story of not understanding
capitalism and i i agree that there it
is important to at least stay afloat but
my light is in heaven my friend i'm not
if i make the light bulbs on earth i
don't i don't want the money for it at
this point man i should be dead tomorrow
that i think is like a a a
sort of leftist ideal
money is means it's access it's power so
if you if if you make code and that code
works really really well and you don't
get money for it how do you make more
code how do you how do you feed the
people who are working for you you need
um
you need what's called i guess they
would call it not money but uh what's
the word when someone has capital you
need capital which is either workforce
power or money so how do you how do you
feed the people who are going to do the
work for you
at that point it's like farm grow your
own food inspire them to start growing
their own food i don't know i can't feed
everybody there's a guy down the street
who's got a whole bunch of corn for sale
he did the money's good money's good
it's currency's cool but we don't always
have to use it this is one of the one of
i think the biggest mistakes that young
people make when it comes to
entrepreneur entrepreneurship i remember
when i was younger and i was talking to
some business people i was probably like
20 or 23 or something and then i was
like look
i don't care about
a million bucks cash i care about making
this thing that works we had a program
for like non-profit fundraising stuff
and they said to me kid we'll give you
some advice never tell that to anybody
because
investors who want to see the succeed
understand that money is how it succeeds
you can't you can't run a company off
good intentions how are you going to pay
your staff how are they going to feed
their family how are they going to pay
their rent how are they going to pay
their mortgage making money doesn't mean
you want a ferrari it means you want to
make sure the machine continues to feed
the families of the people who work for
you so you want to tell everybody your
goal is to make a company that makes
money by doing good
and i'm like good point i get it and
also talk about profit because making
money doesn't mean you're going to make
profit so how much profit are you
intending to make and at what cost
psychological cost what damage to
society it's a lot of unquantifiable
concepts but every everybody thinks
they're the good guy even the people who
work for these big petroleum companies
are convinced they're the good guys and
these activists show up and they say
you're destroying the planet and they
get violent and the people who work for
these oil companies are like i'm doing
everything in my power to make the world
a better place you know what minds we
had to figure out how uh addictive do we
want to make minds.com and i was like 89
that's not ethical you don't want it to
be like a gambling network it's the same
as how profitable do you want your
private company to be like elon said
it's not about money buying twitter's
not about money i assume he's planning
on running it at a loss you know he's
just going to subsidize it
i i think he's talked with morgan
stanley
and if you go to morgan stanley and say
if you give me 20 13 billion dollars i
will lose that money for you they're
gonna say get out no what he did was he
went and said i'm gonna save you money
how i'm gonna i'm gonna dock pay and
fire executive staff
we're gonna turn it around because take
a look at this data these metrics i'm
gonna put my own money in and collateral
and then in three years we're taking the
company public again and we honestly
exactly told that it does have to be
successful to make an impact i mean
and for that you do need to be at least
at least as addictive as your
competitors surely i don't know maybe
but do you really want to play their
game like can you become evil to beat
evil i don't i don't know if
i i understand what you mean well you
can make it more addictive if you want
you know what i was thinking
minds has tokens right you get the my
when you use minds.com you can generate
crypto that's worth money
every post should have a slot machine in
it
you could do that then no one will ever
leave the website i have like a
gamification
a mod for mines that i've built we could
still install it one day where you get
avatars and you can spend mines tokens
to get characters that can you can send
out on missions every day to go get and
then if you click the notification at a
certain at the right moment then they
get the item when they come back and
then you have like a hall of fame with
your item like you just dump money it's
just a money sync but like how how
gamified and addictive is mines is just
a beautiful piece of free software that
i i want to be but it's like yeah like
how sensational do we need to be my
biggest flaw in life personally is
charity i'm too charitable i've always
been too charitable i give my wealth
away before i get it and i haven't used
my money to make money because i feel
like it just felt dirty so thank you for
making the money for me tim well i'll
i'll i'll give you uh uh uh i'll break
it down for in a way that you can
understand ian
you
are playing a game of magic and you have
all of the planes before you with the
good
righteous knights and the angels and
they're all good and charitable and
trying to protect the people
and so you say i'm gonna give this power
away and then along comes a necromancer
who's loaded with swamps and he goes yes
ian give me the power i'll help everyone
and you're like sounds good to me and
you give him the power and then he
laughs at you as he burns everything
down yeah charity they say it's a virtue
but it's also a vice it can be i guess
very very evil people would love to get
access to the free code and let me just
tell you these these left sensorious
people they like zuckerberg he's
probably so excited whenever he sees the
free code come out and he's like great i
can add some of this to my empire yeah
he's gonna have to free his too that
would be great if youtube facebook and
twitter's code was available to make new
networks with it all that'd be super
cool why is it that
gab
interoperability is like a huge do that
could really break the uh big text
pattern why is it that the twitter
alternatives haven't taken off
like why doesn't minds have more uses
than facebook i mean it's better right i
think because their twitter was already
there
the first and best dressed i've heard
you mentioned before right so with with
facebook and twitter it's because people
are there
the real the real platform is the people
i don't do anything on facebook facebook
has all these weird features i don't
care about i use messenger why because
people are on it and so when i want to
message someone i can message them on
facebook
i use twitter mostly well mostly to just
troll because people are on it but
there's less of an impact on other
platforms because people aren't on it i
don't care what twitter can do i can
post words people can get mad about it
yeah it'd be cool if you could log into
twitter and then see your minds like it
was linked to minds and together
what would happen if twitter's code was
forcibly revealed and released to the
people
um i can't i can't foresee exactly
nothing nobody would leave it would get
used yeah nobody would do a network
would take it sure maybe maybe maybe gab
might implement some of it maybe parlor
and getter and truth might implement
that we talked about and minds and then
everyone would be like yeah but
everyone's on twitter so i'll use that
or you could but you could get the same
experience on well you'd have a
different experience but you'd have the
same information from different depends
on how you want to go at it you want to
come with your gab through gab i think i
think the issue is your your perspective
on this is rooted in
you're looking at code because that's
where you come from not realizing that
people care about people not code no i
come from entertainment i'm an actor
that's my that's my i mean like with
minds you're looking at these social
media companies from this minds
perspective and what makes twitter work
is that twitter has people that's it
twitter twitter could reduce the the
amount of characters back to 140. it's
still going to be the dominant platform
which which by the way is why and i
think alum and i have both talked
written about this but this is why the
you know build your own doesn't work
unfortunately i really want truth social
to work i really want getter to work but
people want to go where the people are
right you fish where the fish mermaid
right like like you can you can it's
like imagine if someone said if if the
the lake gets to a certain amount of
users they have to
build a lake or give someone all of the
means to build their own lake it's like
okay
i go to the beach because there's fish
or i go to the lake to fish because
there's fish if someone else builds a
lake and there's no fish in it i can't
fish there but what you can do is build
a channel from one lake to the other if
there's like your lake has all the fish
in the middle and then there's like a
thousand other lakes but they have no
fish you just build a thousand canals
but you can't everyone can fish together
you can't force twitter to allow that
information oh you can break up
monopolies that's free yeah yeah for
sure what i'm saying is some of the code
doesn't change that if you're saying you
want to pass a law that says they have
to
create interoperability between other
networks let's have a conversation about
that
let's see i the ideal would be if it was
easy for everyone to just make a post
that gets broadcast to twitter to gab to
minds to all the platforms
instantaneously but that doesn't happen
without interoperability to some extent
yeah we tried to do that with mines in
the early days but we didn't have access
to the code so we couldn't do it yeah
using their proprietary apis and stuff
yeah and the great thing about platform
like mines and gab that are based on
values is that you know when you go on
them
they're not going to sell you out in
free speech it's not going to be like
twitter where they promised it to you in
the first few years and then took it
away from you years later after you
built your following i think gab um may
have banned advocacy of porn
yes they did so they're not a completely
free speech platform but they're not
going to ban you for political speech oh
i don't know
i don't even i don't even trust mines
and i help build the network you can't
really give that power to one person
because if bill leaves and another guy
comes in he can ban everyone but i think
that's fine that's the private network
if it wants to do it will i have my own
version of it will gab ban you for
saying
i believe a law should be passed
legalizing porn blah blah blah
my understanding is that that torba said
i could be wrong so you know if i'm
wrong about this but there was a tweet
where they said you will not be allowed
to advocate for this you'll be banned
degenerate or something i described
gabba is a free speech friendly platform
they're not completely free speech i'll
i'll grant you that well i mean to to um
they're private companies they can ban
whoever they want and that shouldn't
change but we should also be able to
spin up our own versions of it so that i
can ban it'll create a marketplace of
terms as opposed to a marketplace of
code
my position is
gab is different than twitter right so
i'm i'm pretty comfortable with gab
banning whoever they want i don't want
them to but if they do they do
um you know if christian mingle wants to
only have christians on their site
that's fine but once you become the
actual digital public square you have
different responsibilities and that's
where like i think section 230 comes in
uh ultimately like you know we like
section 230 for the small guys for the
media medium guys but once you're the
largest guys uh twitter facebook
google i think you have an obligation to
speak was it wasn't the famous quote
free is in freedom not as in beer when
it came to open source and free software
yeah it doesn't mean it doesn't cost
anything it means that it's free and
available for people to use no like
you're free in the united states that
doesn't mean that
you don't cost anything free isn't
freedom right means you can use these
platforms to be free but it's not free
as in beer like we just give it to you
exactly yeah you can still you can still
sell free software for instance
my problem with what you're saying is
having anyone in charge even if section
230 is like you have to do this and this
is having anyone or group of people in
charge of free speech is
is antithetical to free speech
the idea
well i mean the responsibility of
government is to secure the liberties of
its citizens so technically i mean that
is putting free speech in the hands of
government um a government could either
respect it or not government is
irrelevant culture is everything the
constitution says the right the people
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed good luck in
new york new jersey
maryland
hawaii california i mean the list goes
on
your rights are absolutely infringed i
love bringing this up maryland has
banned the m1a a three i believe it's a
308 it might be a 7 uh 762 actually um
they're sort of interchangeable but the
pressure is different so i think it
might be 762. uh scar 20s the more ar
style 308 legal
it's it's remarkably insane ksg25
double mag tube 25
25 round pump action shotgun totally
legal
semi-auto uh benelli
illegal the laws make literally no sense
so your rights are infringed upon to
absurd degrees it's about who's in
charge and where they're in charge and
uh you know we're talking about
government solutions the problem of tech
centralization and big tech uh
i i help persuade republicans that uh
they should actually abandon some of the
free market stuff when it comes to
regulating big tech i was doing that
when they had power in 2017 and 18. but
the people have power now are the
democrats and they are never going to
pass any kind of bill that will make
censorship harder in fact they're going
to try and pass bills that make
censorship
easier and that's something we have to
be very cautious about because there are
lots of interests that want republicans
to jump on every single anti-big tech
effort just because anti-big tech but we
need to look at the detail of the bills
then we need a convention of states and
term limits because we can't we can't
get these people to vote term limits for
themselves but we need them out they
don't understand what is going on in the
tech sector
there's too many of them they don't know
this is crazy well let's take section
230 as an example there are many bad
ways to reform section 230. uh disney
has been pushing section 230 reform
behind the scenes in dc for a very long
time
because they uh they hate big tech they
think big tech has made it easier to
steal their copyrighted materials
uh their section 230 reforms are almost
always bad we uh in fact most of the
section 230 reform is pushed by
corporations are almost always bad
there's just one specific part of the
law
that allows them to censor anything they
consider to be objectionable that is the
part that needs to change and anything
else that people are coming to you
saying we need to perform section 230
this way without or abolish it
altogether be very cautious of them
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already please hit that like button
smash it and subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends if you
really want to help us out and go to
timcast.com become a member to support
our journalists to support our work and
we're going to have a members only show
that goes up at 11 p.m monday through
thursday that'll be up tonight let's
read what you guys have to say fair
shark says can ian explain why graphene
is better than borophene or is borophene
the future i got sent the boar if you've
seen the video
forget graphing boraphine i'm like all
right first of all they're probably both
awesome and i started to watch a video i
watched like three minutes of it
i don't know i don't know anything about
morphine yet i guess i should i got like
25 people have sent me that video
all right caleb south says ian is what
happens when you put your points in
intelligence and charisma but use wind
wisdom as a dump stat love you man never
change
well that's funny maybe i'm not as wise
as i think
wise alvin says tornados in oklahoma
tonight just saw a pot farm get
demolished on news 9. whoa crazy man i
hope everybody's all right do you guys
see that viral video from the drone of
the tornado ripping through was it
kansas or something no no crazy video
wild just like houses just coming off
the ground and just flying away yeah we
have these human problems but it's good
to put things in perspective sometimes
all right
what is this joseph
liberty says
i want this guy with an accent to break
me about why argyle socks are better
than just plain black ankle socks
what
wait i i didn't even understand the
question i think he's assuming you're
wearing argyle socks are you i'm wearing
pure black socks right now maybe i'm not
a proper english person i guess all
right that's a uh what's the word
amalgam okay we got a chat from somebody
with no name what say you about in vitro
fertilization and the possible 10 plus
fertilized eggs some of these women may
have should the states that outlaw
abortion forces women to birth all of
these
what are you asking me
i would say i really have a dark opinion
of uh ivf because they are fertilizing
and then discarding of many human eggs i
see this as a big issue and i think we
definitely need to reform that process i
think that everyone should be looking at
adoption before they look at idea that's
just my two cents jumping back to socks
it just occurred to me that justin
trudeau ruined elaborate socks forever
yeah he did but so if a woman does get
ifv or ivf sorry and she has 10
you know viable fetuses in her like
getting to work what should she do just
have 10 babies i don't know what to say
to that she probably should have thought
of that before she got ivf i figured
that'd be completely preventable you
know
i don't know tough
adrienne well how they used to have like
10 kids only two of them would survive
and others do it in the womb
all right adrian contreras says this
dude should be giving awesome gadgets to
james bond with that accent
did you know allen is james bond yeah he
is ken says heard 10 year old in other
room listening to freedom tunes he said
it was recommended i don't talk politics
with kid he is he assured me it's funny
dad
that's right freedom tunes is very funny
that's fantastic all right
caveman says get tom mcdonald on the
show tim you mentioned it a while back
yeah i've talked to tom before he's a
rad dude up to him i mean he's a busy
guy you know
raymond g stanley jr says biden the
great unifier it's work it's working
[Music]
matthew reckham says to everyone who
keeps saying we're in dark times now let
me remind you that the movie demolition
man based on brave new world and
predicted self-driving electric cars
zoom meetings culturally enforced
germaphobia and more is and more is set
in 2032 buckle up buttercup that is an
absolute classic everyone go watch that
movie i love when they're like he
doesn't know how to use the shells
that was good
you saw it right demolition man yeah
yeah
he gets frozen and then they take him
out in the in the future to stop a
terrorist time and he like he every time
he swears a machine prints out a ticket
a fine for swearing
he just wears a bunch more that's great
he no no he goes to the bathroom and
he's like how do i do this there's no
toilet paper and they're like use the
shells and he's like what so then he
walks up and starts swearing and then
takes all the paper and goes in the
bathroom with it that's cool that's
perfect yeah that's a good movie free
paper
all right let's grab some more
what is this
roberto lara says i was hoping for far
right musketeers but ultra maga sounds
like whoever wrote that for biden copy
stole it from goku's power levels
biden is literally stealing from history
and making everyone forget the actual
history somebody said i think i may have
missed it but they were like we need a
trump anime one one punch man you guys
ever see one punch man yeah it was
really really popular among non-anime
fans for some reason and it's like it's
it's a good it's about a guy who's just
like for some reason
godly and he could like punch and just
feed anybody but he's kind of dumb
so it's funny but i'd love to see a one
trump man and it's just like someone
made um there's an anime called my hero
academia
and they made it there's the the
superhero in it that everyone loves is
called almight so then someone made a
comic called walmite and it's trump as
the main guy
[Laughter]
superhero trump someone is working on an
ultra maga comic book right now it's
gonna be great it's gonna be amazing
chris light says we love tim cast irl
but tim please stop saying russell
feathers it's ruffle feathers lmao
russell jimmies russell jimmy's is that
what it is i was combining the two
that's true yeah it's good good combo
joseph liberty says can you bring the
dad off of gen x talks on here i don't
know who that is who is that either look
that up maybe an x talks
all right maxwell griffin says why don't
people identify as supreme court
justices and vote to uphold roe v wade
i identify
they want to expand the court cigars and
sig arms the us government is the most
violent and extreme group that has ever
existed in this country their body count
of innocent people is in the millions
beast yeah i believe that is true and
correct lots of children too under obama
dead
all right raymond g stanley jr says will
it ever stop yo i don't know
light up the base and i'll glow to the
extreme iraq maga-like ultra civil war
yeah tim told you ice ice baby wonderful
all right toy painter says there will be
no civil war if it comes to violence the
right will roll over and take it like
the left prison
be
the right are all talk and no action
sadly well i don't completely disagree
with that but the right sir been winning
a whole lot of stuff in the past week or
so it's been crazy it's been great it's
been just chaos and implosion among the
left they've been freaking out
john curry says tim that was melissa
francis who wouldn't let gingrich talk
about soros her husband works for soros
no way really is that that's insane
interesting
interesting
all right cornelius says i missed last
night's stream so i'm sending this now
ian the human brain isn't finished
developing until around 25 years old so
we can abort children so can we abort
children and young adults then being
born doesn't make you human it is what
you are no abort is in reference to a
pregnancy that is aborted so anyone
that's already born cannot be aborted by
that definition also no the answer is no
to your question
paul renfer says where when is the
freedom tunes stereotypical animation
parody where trump's supporters power up
and get trump here yeah oh that's a good
that's a good bit actually their hair
turns gold but instead of spiking like
goku it swirls like trump yes
ultra mega
navy sooner says since we know what
national socialism is can we change the
dem party to the glotti party global
socialist party time to start demonizing
them like they do to everybody else
you know i think what works though is
that we don't play their stupid games
right the regular people are looking for
the truth and when the democrats lie
they go if you just if you just come out
and start lying the way they do people
are going to be like ah screw it what's
the point and you have to you have to
have the institutional power to lie and
get away with it if we lie i'll just
point it out well i think when boomers
age out as it were
cable news is gone just completely gone
congress protects that
bails them out yeah yeah but it the the
key demo viewership is in the hundreds
of thousands i think tucker carlson is
like four or five hundred and then cnn
is like 89 000 people like that's crazy
i posted a chicken sitting video and it
got more views than some of these some
of these hosts on cnn get remarkable
i will say politicians do less listen to
the old media more than new media though
because they don't understand new media
and how powerful it is it depends if
they want to run for president right
they start to listen to the new media
they actually say that this new
alternative media is the fifth estate
and i guess the first three states are
the three branches of government you
have to look it up
oh gee lesbian says tim i'm still
laughing at the firefighter comment the
other day although we don't agree on
everything i love watching your show hey
really appreciate it
we were when we were talking about was
that was that the story the joke we made
about how the woman would give birth to
a baby oh yeah
leave it at the fire department you can
drop babies off in the fire department
and then
the joke was like this is actually how
you make new firefighters so that danny
polish
yeah they have to they have to raise the
baby now and the baby is like just like
the firefighter teaching how to fight
fires and then you end up with this
superhero firefighter telling his story
about how he came to be the best
firefighter in the world i love it that
was really funny
the firefighters teaching them to cook
oh gee lesbian says i'm convinced my mom
is a npc
no no i'm sad to hear it
that's crazy when you talk to the people
when you talk to the dmt people like
proponents of it about this stuff it's a
it's weird how the psychedelic and the
political kind of merge
because a lot of people were saying npc
non-player character as like kind of an
insult referencing someone just not
paying attention and not caring but then
you take you talk to the people about
dmt and you're like oh man because you
know we were talking to michael malus
and i i may be getting this wrong but he
was saying like
we're like meat puppets of some kind of
entities or something
and then i'm like what if some people
don't have an entity controlling them
the way you know you do when you do dmt
like are those npcs calcific
calcification of the pineal gland they
can be shaken awake of course you can't
have an npc without pc in there um yeah
they seem like npcs because they're not
like aware as aware as you are but that
doesn't mean that they're not available
to play
sean anderson says there are two things
that hold the usa together boomers in
the dollar the next 10 years we'll see
both become irrelevant
yeah we were talking about the russia
ukraine stuff the dollar the american
hegemony yeah over the dollar this is
something that's going to be a huge
story coming up because russia found
ways to kind of go around by selling
their their oil they're in an alliance
with china on this stuff so it's going
to be really you know scary it's
interesting because when we talk about
um strasshau generational theory
we are looking at i think the end of the
winter the fourth turning in 2028 which
means 2026 should be extreme turmoil i
wonder if four more years is enough to
see many boomers and older generation
leave younger generation come in that
will create a massive upset
i don't know
it's possible i fear my concern is
without term limits in congress that it
won't they're just going to ride the
wave into the ground i i can't
mathematically i don't see any other it
seems probable
i'm into term limits ready to rumble the
question is where are the term limits
for the deep state
yeah four years yeah for all
administrative state
you'd have to do both i think you would
have that's what thomas massey said too
yeah
i think it was thomas no no it wasn't it
was it was starting to rp ready to
rumble says i can't believe you just met
seinfeld seinfeld was the funniest tv
show ever created you need more seinfeld
in your life tim you know maybe it was
at the time because i remember watching
it but i wonder if it's like a certain
kind of humor for what like boomers and
gen x
nothing yeah it's not a show about
nothing it's a show about four friends
who have emotional problems and and
like
that was that was the idea they tried
claiming seinfeld a show about nothing
no it's four friends and they have
interpersonal drama like any other
sitcom it's about a comedian living in
new york with a wacky neighbor and a
short friend who has life troubles and
there were a lot of really the show was
really funny in a lot of ways but i feel
like that kind of humor maybe was a lot
funnier back in the day i don't find it
as funny today it was groundbreaking
when it came out right yeah we had the
internet now it was michael richards
really one of my musical comedy was off
the charts one of my favorite episodes
well i just watched a funny bit it was
on i think reddit post trump posted on
twitter uh who was it it might have been
elijah schaefer posted this he uh
someone said everyone needs a friend
like kramer kramer walks into jerry's
apartment and he's like hey i gotta go
over to do this thing do you wanna and
then kramer goes sure and he's like i
could have just said anything huh and
he's like at least walk out kramer was
great i was thinking about this this uh
recently i think traditional comedians
can't compete with the internet yeah
because they don't have that instant
feedback
like they never had to subject
themselves to reddit upvotes or having
replies on a 4chan thread well uh
comedians go do
standup to test out right jokes and then
go on tour with the internet you can try
things out in real time yeah and you're
doing it with thousands and tens of
thousands of people one of the best
episodes of seinfeld is when george
decides to do everything of the opposite
of what he would normally do cause he's
like his life sucks he can't get a date
his job is you know so he's like
whatever i'm going to do i'm going to do
the opposite of it and so he like orders
the opposite sandwich then you normally
everything goes great for him that was
brilliant writing that was about larry
david's um
steinbrenner is it was incredible
incredible
oh i figured it was tom garrett that was
talking about uh term limits for the
administrative state when he was on the
show
uh yes we've had many a conversation
about limits it's tough it is difficult
conversation because then you get rid of
the ron paul's you know or the rand
pauls but like we said up to now i love
rand paul i love rand paul and you see
he votes for something or he's on
support him from something like what
we're talking about earlier james nelson
says ian doesn't get it the code is
worthless and can be reverse engineered
big tech's power comes from its user
base they have critical mass yeah that's
why the interoperability part of it so
you get not only the software code but
the access to the people as well
i don't know how you mandate a company
to build a thing you know like you can't
go to an apple orchard and be like we
mandate that you build an apple launcher
they're gonna be like okay we can't do
that like well you have to you mean
command like google to interoperate with
other people tell going to twitter and
saying you need to now make your company
able to interact with other networks in
it they can be like that you're asking
us to build a thing we don't know how to
build no i know that has that has
happened before and they did that to the
telephone companies way back in the day
they did it to british retail banks
after the financial crisis they forced
them to give all their customers their
data in a universal standardized format
so they could easily transfer it between
banks interesting but so i'm talking
about they have to build a bridge
so i suppose it's one thing to be like i
think the eu wanted to standardize phone
chargers so that every phone would same
charge and they stopped having this
problem all these different chargers the
issue with
twitter is that you're asking them to
build a protocol for which their
co like their things on twitter can be
transported in real time actively
forever between different networks i
think that it's already it's theirs just
proprietary at this point the api it
could be wrong it's a question of you
know can they continue to be profitable
and be a successful business if you ask
them to do this where i don't think it's
ever fair or smart for government to say
let's you know force this company to
build this and then they would rather go
out of business right it's it's i don't
think it's possible um to force their
api open to require twitter to send
their data out to third parties because
it would
make them worthless it would cost them a
lot of money to do and then they're
losing what makes the network work in
the first place twitter needs to be able
to make money unless you want to
nationalize it and pay for it through
taxpayers then it's forced subsidization
but if twitter has to give its code away
and then people do decide with
interoperability i can go to gab instead
then twitter loses membership and
advertising revenue and collapses but if
you're on nothing if you're on gab and
i'm reading your twitter feed twitter's
still getting my activity even though
i'm on gab but they're not running ads
no i think the ad revenue model's is
good so then who then they're not gonna
get the memberships um
you might be able to work out
memberships where like if someone
subscribes to the mega network or uh
that twitter gets twenty four percent
gab gets twenty percent minds get twenty
percent or if you subscribe and you're
connected with like what networks are
you in that you want to subscribe
for they all get a piece of it with a
smart contract i don't like i don't
think the answer is for the government
to go in with a sledgehammer and just
destroy twitter as much as i like the
idea i think it's that we have to build
these open source interoperable systems
and make people use them also like
incentivize also do we like the idea
this is this is another reason why i
come back to you know look at what the
tech regulations are on an individual
level and also who they apply to
uh you know you asked me two months ago
should we regulate twitter i'd say yes
you asked me today i'd say no maybe not
maybe not because it's not about you
know do we support regulation or do we
not support regulation but who's in
charge who's in charge of enforcing the
regulation wackos at the ftc and who's
going to be affected by them uh luckily
not twitter under most of the antitrust
laws but uh i'm sure the democrats will
try also what is the regulation that's a
vague term right exactly you've got to
look at each and end each individual
proposed regulation to see what it does
and importantly who will enforce it this
crazy person they hide at the ftc called
meredith whitaker and the ftc is going
to be enforcing a lot of the anti-trust
stuff i think zack bell might have the
best response to ian he says please
explain how freeing the code won't just
open up the floodgates to allow hackers
to utilize or even destroy the system
um well there's security code that you
don't have to open up but as long as the
network itself is available to be
interoperated with from a user-based
perspective i think that kind of solves
the problem and then what they'll do is
they'll entwine specific core
functionality with security and say you
can't do anything about it
yeah i i've never seen a network have
theirs all their security open i mean
that makes no sense that would be like
leaving a copy of your key on the front
porch you know if they don't give up
their their their code for security how
could someone actually make
spin up their own version
you don't need you don't well they would
get distracted i'm not a coded guy i'm
not a coder so i would like to bring
people that are code developers in to
talk have a greater conversation about
that because that's a good question so
uh to clarify to expand upon this for
those i don't understand the
if a random if the whole world knew
facebook's code they would find every
exploit imaginable to break in spy steal
and destroy everything from the company
you'd also have people empowering like
strengthening the code and making it
more resistant that's not it's not open
source
so they could probably do like bug hunt
and then good people might help but
they're called zero so a zero day
exploit means it's spent zero days in
the public sphere
you open up the code from these
companies and
you're going to have a million hackers
discovering a million zero days and then
you're going to cross your fingers the
good guys yeah minds doesn't have their
their um security code is not free that
would be insane because then people
could just hack it like you're saying
what you can still interoperate with
what about the code for like logging in
i don't know i don't know i gotta ask
bill i'd have to because if if they
release their code that allows you to
create your login system then you are
not secure and anyone can just yeah we
need like your account we need a unique
login like a passport that where you can
log into other networks with your
personal passport wallet type thing like
facebook well it's kind of what we're
building with the foundation i think the
issue is
any any code for any functionality of
mines
that goes out allows someone to exploit
the system and makes it so you're not
safe
anymore
any code
the code for for like the the
recommendation algorithm that's probably
fine but someone will then exploit the
recommendation algorithm to maximize
viewership for themselves if you're
smarter i'm really not as concerned with
security as i am with freedom at this
point
i i i can agree with that to the extent
that
um
for this show for instance we have to
have security because i'm not saying
that we shouldn't have security but in
certain ways
if we didn't have security i don't know
if we could keep doing right now like in
the united states they say it's freedom
and then security but like without the
security we wouldn't have no freedom if
we didn't guard and protect our borders
and our streets with police and military
we wouldn't be free to walk around
without getting our backs down so the
issue is facebook is so big
if they released their code they would
be destroyed instantly
i don't think so no it's too big it
would take for a long time and bad
policies for them to lose their users at
that point let's read some more super
chats
sterile hybrid says this is for last
night's episode as an intersex person
i'm no fan of trans ideology sex does
not exist on a spectrum as a result of
my condition i'm a mix between the two
not some magical third sex nor
transgender prop interesting
james says coca-cola has a billion users
a day should they release their secret
recipe
uh not unless they're part of the
commons
what does that mean
if everyone uses coca-cola's network
every day to communicate with each other
or to get from place to place
all right calvin ramsey says hey tim 30
year old skater here curious who your
favorite skaters are currently
been digging ace pelka and mike anderson
lately love the show uh johnny geiger
is
um right yeah johnny
one of the best he's a flip trick guy
and just absolutely one of the best
really great game of skate with him over
at the barracks i forgot the name of the
guy who's up against uh joslin i'm
actually wearing his shoes right now and
these are like some of the best shoes oh
you can't even see it because the
cameras are cool uh so i got the joslins
on right now these are great shoes i've
mostly been doing in-line
recently uh just because just having fun
just doing something new and something
different so i haven't i just kind of
felt like i got to the point in
skateboarding where i've done too much
like i've just done so much in
skateboarding i wanted to do something
different so i started blading we got
some people here who played and everyone
kind of does it the other issue too was
we built the skatepark
nobody used it it was literally just me
skating by myself all the time and the
thing about inline is that almost
everyone knows how to inline so it's
like you get you get a pair of blades
and someone can put them on at least
ride around and go do stuff so it's
actually just easier to do community
stuff with within line but uh it's still
skating every so every every every so
often but i thought a good thing to get
would be those rings you know the
hanging swinging rings like that'd be a
cool thing to get yeah we gotta we want
to do some kind of like parkour
little thing maybe we can do it in the
front
because arm day
gotta get you gotta get arm game
all right
hugh jennings says never listened to
alan before his voice reminds me of alec
guinness a lot of people commenting on
your voice that's a huge huge compliment
i am going to give gadgets to james bond
after this by the way he's just
finishing his uh gender transition
oh yes rachel transition right that's
right
okay
what did we do i just had one where did
it go
stuart cooper says techy me partially
sees ian's point of view on the free the
source code but creator me sees an issue
the intellectual property loss could
apply to written work such as novels and
screenplays not if they're not the
commons this is a very unique type of
technology if you you can't screenplays
are not used to communicate across
large suaves or so it's no i'm talking
about communication tech platforms it's
a very specific function
i don't know maybe there would have to
be something like well first of all the
security issue i think you can't get
around like if people can see the code
for how messenger works on facebook they
will learn how to inject and take over
messenger and it's it you can already do
it china will do it well so uh when i
went to venezuela
uh i was
say you know doing a bit of trolling too
because they were threatening me and
stuff when i left i got a message from a
friend of mine saying dude what's going
on the fbi called me you need to call me
back right now
so i call him he doesn't answer calling
me doesn't answer call me doesn't answer
wait a few hours he calls me back and
he's like this is someone i hadn't
talked to in like four years and he was
like dude
what's going on you calling me all
morning and i was like what's up with
this fbi hitting you up and he says what
are you talking about and i was like you
messaged me on facebook
and he was like no no i didn't dudes
like i haven't talked to in like four
years and i was like okay i got a
message from you on facebook saying the
fbi called you and he's like bro i
didn't i didn't do that
so what we think was i consulted with
some security experts i screenshotted
the image sent it to him i think i still
have it actually i think it posted it
not too long ago and what they said was
venezuelan hackers
did an injection attack on facebook
they knew where to send certain
information to make it appear as though
my friend had messaged me
they wanted me to make a phone call so
they could pinpoint my location by
triangulating cell towers they thought i
was still in the country i wasn't yeah
those networks are compromised anyway um
and we need peer-to-peer encrypted
messaging on basically as a function
written into our daily behavior
mick chilla says facebook has an entire
library of open source code to support
developers it literally took me 15
seconds to figure that out on google
there's some yeah most companies have
some open source code google does too
alphabet i guess i should call it
seriously jk says ian i am an expert on
ip law and am a sme in software
architecture you have no idea what your
ideas even mean you don't understand
open source sw licenses or business it's
brutal to listen to you say this stuff
that's really vague man you got to be a
little more specific if you want to make
an argument
max stahl says tim have you ever thought
about what it'd be like to be the carrot
from pajama sam what is pajama sam i
have no idea
i don't know what that means
jxn says twitter is working on freeing
the code by developing an open standard
for social media see jack dorsey's
december 11 2019 thread on twitter
search twitter is funding a small on
google first result yeah i know he's
been saying he's never done it that's
why i'm kind of like i don't know
whatever
we're working on right now with in open
index protocol as part of the package
that we're building right now
all right patrice
bake
well this last one says lydia carlin
borisenko challenged you to a boxing
match she's well informed about women
leaving the left
a boxing match huh i'm pretty sure i'm
about
a foot taller than her but we could try
or probably different weight classes
might be fun
well all right all right everybody if
you have not already please smash that
like button to help support our work
subscribe to this channel share the show
take the url post it wherever because
the grassroots marketing is how we've
grown this show and got to the point
where we are so uh eternally grateful
for all the support head over to
timcast.com be a member we're gonna have
that members only show coming up at 11pm
you can follow the show at timcast irl
you can follow me personally at timcast
basically everywhere i guess me saying
that has resulted in people following me
on twitter because i was just thinking
like why do i have so many twitter
followers
i guess that's it well thank you for
following me elon's probably helping too
yeah elon tweeted out that meme and me
crazy days uh al you guys want to shout
anything out alan
uh just as always follow my writing at
breitbart news i post my articles on
twitter as well for the latest
happenings in the world of silicon
valley bias and censorship
i have a big paper coming out tomorrow
about big tech's uh interference in the
2020 election it's uh
bigtechpaper.app
cool awesome and twitter what's your
twitter handle just john schweppe
beautiful uh you guys follow me ian
crossland.net where you can find all my
social medias and get in touch with me
there i'll catch you later thank you
guys for tuning in this evening i had a
great time learning about all this techy
stuff and a lot of fun talking to these
two cool dudes you guys can follow me on
twitter and minds.com at sourpatchlitz
sour patch lids i forgot my own name and
you guys may see all my socials at
sourpatchlids.me
thanks for hanging out everybody we will
see you all at timcast.com in the
meantime why don't you go watch some
chicken sleep over at youtube.com
chickencity or chickencitylive.com
thanks for hanging out we'll see you all
soon
you